welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn
so far we have mastered devops with
cloud in today's session we will be
learning the popular devops tools
devops is important because of its
software development and operations
approach that enables faster development
of new products and easier maintenance
of existing deployments this achievement
is only possible due to the most
effective and efficient tools of devops
today we will be learning the same so
without further ado let's get started
we shall begin with having a basic
understanding of what devops is
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand the basics of devops its
relevance in the present scenario and
several devops phases after we know
about devops we shall begin with
learning different devops tools in
detail we shall learn about git followed
by github and in the process we shall
learn the various github commands second
we shall see what jenkins is jenkins
pipeline and how we install jenkins
after that we shall move on to docker
and check what docker and docker
container is all about and in the
process we shall see the process to
install docker
moving further we shall learn the basics
of kubernetes the difference between
communities and docker and kubernetes on
aws
the following tool in our list would be
puppet
where we shall know what puppet is
why we use puppet and the process to
install it moving forward we shall learn
about ansible its installation process
and what are the benefits of using
ansible
the last tool in our list is selenium
where we will learn about what selenium
is all about and all the selenium suit
tools followed by its installation
process
while we are learning all these tools we
shall understand them with a hands-on
demo making the understand much more
effective and more accessible and
finally we will have a piece of deep
knowledge regarding devops and several
devops tools we should look into some of
the most prominent devops interview
questions that will help you excel in
your forthcoming devops interviews so
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with our first topic
right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments
the development team that develops the
plan designs and builds the system from
scratch and the operation team for
testing and implementation of whatever
is developed the operations team gave
the development team feedback on any
bugs that needed fixing and any rework
required invariably the development team
would be idle awaiting feedback from the
operations team
this undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle
there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth
though there may be communication
challenges devops manages a streamlined
flow between the teams and makes the
software development process successful
the devops culture is implemented in
several phases with the help of several
tools let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like get and merged when
required this process is called version
control the code is then made executable
with tools like maven and gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code has passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase and
this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase
jenkins is the tool that sends the code
for building and testing if the code
passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration there are many
tech giants and organizations that have
opted for the devops approach for
example amazon netflix walmart facebook
and adobe
netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007
in 2014 it was estimated that a downtime
for about an hour would cost netflix two
hundred thousand dollars however now
netflix can cope with such issues they
opted for devops in the most fantastic
way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment without
affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d
none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one gateway
devops
and if you're also looking forward to
doing the same and excel in devops check
out simply learn's postgraduate program
in devops design and collaboration with
caltech ctme
the program can help you master several
in-demand devops skills and tools like
continuous integration and delivery
devops on cloud kubernetes docker and
much more
we hope you enjoyed this video today
we're going to introduce you to devops
we're going to go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at devops and how devops
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical
devops delivery and then the tools used
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within devops finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering solutions not just it
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history it
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your client and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send the requirements back
to the programmer with feedback this
allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop where we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client to
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and it may be small features or
bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works
so this is where devops really comes in
and let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
ops team and the dev team and so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that
it's based on data so let's step through
the different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to agile and
what i'd like to point out at time is
that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
coders actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as maven
and gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire dev ops toolset this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have a
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your sprint cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
google google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on youtube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with netflix is that netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart tvs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity and
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment
and you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos but
that are actually working cohesively
together and that there is continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
that your consumer your customer is
constantly being delighted hello this is
matthew from simply learn so what are we
going to cover today so we're going to
introduce the concept of version control
that you'll use within your devops
environment
then we'll talk about the different
tools are available in a distributed
version control system we'll highlight a
product called git which is typically
used for version control today and
you'll also go through what are the
differences between get and github you
may have used github in the past or
other products like get lab and we'll
explain what are the differences between
git and git and services such as github
and git lab we'll break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like and how do you go through and
create forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally i'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of git against a public service
such as github all right let's talk a
little bit about version control systems
so you may have already been using a
version control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as microsoft's team
foundation services but essentially the
use of a version control system allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program that such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the version one changes that you had
then the person would then uh later on
check out that code and then be a
version two and add it to that code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be
stored in a centralized location however
the challenge you're running is that
it's very difficult for large groups to
work simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a vcs system a version
control system
demonstrates that you're able to store
multiple versions of a solution in a
single repository now let's take a step
at some of the challenges that you have
with traditional version control systems
and see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed vcs server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed vcs
environment is get now you may remember
that we actually covered git in a
previous video and we'll uh reference
that video for you so we start off with
our remote git repository and people are
making updates to the copy of their code
into a local environment that local
environment can be updated manually and
then periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so your git
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get git
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that
remote hub server git is used to track
the changes of the source code and
allows large teams to work
simultaneously with each other it
supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about git versus github so
get is a software tool whereas github is
a service and i'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software tool for git locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service is actually hosted on a website
get is actually the software that used
to manage different versions of source
code whereas github is used to have a
copy of the local repository stored on
the service on the website itself get
provides command line tools that allow
you to interact with your files whereas
git help has a graphical interface that
allows you to check in and check out
files so let me just show you the two
tools here so here i am at the git
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do version control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with github there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to github git lab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as microsoft
visual studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of visual studio team services
also provides this same ability
but github it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to github and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment i'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact i think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on github at the moment that
number's probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project i would certainly encourage you
to start at github to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in github
certainly if you're doing anything with
them azure you'll find that there are
thousands forty five thousand azure
projects currently being worked on
interestingly enough github was recently
acquired by microsoft and microsoft is
fully embracing open source technologies
so that's essentially the difference
between get and github one is a piece of
software and that's git and one is a
service that supports the ability of
using the software and that's github so
let's dig deeper into the actual git
architecture itself so the working
directory is the folder where you are
currently working on your get project
and we'll do a demo later on where you
can actually see how we can actually
simulate each of these steps so you
start off with your working directory
where you store your files and then you
add your files to a staging area where
you are getting ready to commit your
files back to the main branch on your
git project you will want to push out
all your changes to a local repository
after you've made your changes and these
will commit those files and get them
ready for synchronization with the
service and will then push your services
out to the remote repository an example
of a remote repository would be github
later when you want to update your code
before you write any more code you would
pull the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the main line code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure that that a the code remains at
very high quality and b that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning and get so
both of these terms are quite old terms
when it comes to development but forking
is certainly a term that goes way way
way back long before we had distributed
cvs systems such as the ones that were
using with git to fork a piece of
software is a particular open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entirety a
clone and this is important when it
comes to working with git a clone is
identical with the same teams and same
structuring as the main project itself
so when you download the code you're
downloading exact copy of that code with
all the same security and access rights
as the main code and then you can then
check that code back in and potentially
your code because it is identical could
potentially become the main line code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with git
you can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly where
you have large teams this works really
well when you have product teams where
the teams themselves are self-empowered
you can do a concept what's called
branching and get and so say for
instance you are working on a new
feature that new feature and the main
version of the project have to still
work simultaneously so what you can do
is you can create a branch of your code
so you can actually work on the new
feature whereas the rest of the team
continue to work on the main branch of
the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in services software the team is
working on from a remote server and get
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and re-establish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
branch will not be able to branch their
code back into the mainline branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process
so you want to go ahead and fork the
code that you're working on so let's use
this scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually go and you
can take the version of the mainline
branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainland branch it's now a
separate fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code i know i've
certainly made errors in my code it's
great to have other team members that
have your back and can come in and check
and see what they can do to improve the
code so to do that you have to then add
them as a collaborator now you do that
in github you can give them permission
within github itself that's really easy
to do super visual interface that allows
you to do the work quickly and easily
and depending on the type of permissions
you want to give them sometimes it could
be very limited permissions it may be
just to be able to read the files
sometimes it's being able to go in and
make all the changes you can go through
all the different permission settings on
github to actually see what you can do
but you'll be able to make changes so
that people can actually have access to
your repository and then you as a team
can then start working together on the
same code let's step through branching
and get so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code
the circles that we have here on the
screen show various different commits
that have been made so we can keep track
of the master branch and then the
branches that have come off which have
the new features and they can be many
branches and get so get keeps you the
new features you're working on in
separate branches until you're ready to
merge them back in with the main branch
so let's talk a little bit about that
merge process so you're starting with
the master branch which is the blue line
here and then here we have a separate
parallel branch which has the new
features so if we're to look at this
process the base commit of feature b is
the branch f is what's going to merge
back into the master branch and it has
to be said there can be so many
divergent branches but eventually you
want to have everything merged back into
the master branch let's step through get
rebase so again we have a similar
situation where we have a branch that's
being worked in parallel to the master
branch and we want to do a get rebase so
we're at stage c and what we've decided
is that we want to reset the project so
that everything from here on out with
along the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch we'll be adding in new
features along this new rebased
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase you unplug a branch and
replug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new master branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single master branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote suppose there are two developers
working together on an application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers they're always working on the
latest code so you can pull any changes
that you have made to your forked remote
repository to your local repository the
command to be able to do that is written
here and we'll go through a demo of how
to actually do that command in a little
bit good news is if there are no changes
you'll get a notification saying that
you're already up to date and if there
is a change it will merge those changes
to your local repository and you get a
list of the changes that have been made
remotely so let's step through some of
the commands that we have in git so git
and it initializes a local git
repository on your hard drive git add
adds one or more files to your staging
area git commit dash m commit message is
a commit changes the get command commits
changes to head up so the git command
commits changes to your local staging
area get status checks the status of
your current repository and lists the
files you have changed get locked
provides a list of all the commits made
on your current branch get diff use the
changes that you've made to the file so
you can actually have files next to each
other you can actually see
the differences between the two files a
git push origin branch name so the name
of your branch command will push the
branch to the remote repository so that
others can use it and this is what you
do at the end of your project get config
global username will tell get who you
are by configuring the author name we'll
go through that in a moment get config
global user email will tell get the
author of by the email id git clone
creates a git repository copy from a
remote source
git remote add origin server connects
the local repository to the remote
server and adds the server to be able to
push to it get branch and then the
branch name will create a new branch for
you to create a new feature that you may
be working on uh git checkout and then
the branch name will allow you to switch
from one branch to another branch git
merge branch name or merge a branch into
the active branch so if you're working
on a new feature you're going to merge
that into the main branch a get rebase
will reapply commits on top of another
base tip and get rebates will reapply
commits on top of another base tip and
these are just some of the popular get
commands there are some more but you can
certainly dig into those as you're
working through using get so let's go
ahead and run a demo using get so now we
are going to do a demo using get on our
local machine and github as the remote
repository for this to work i'm going to
be using a couple of tools first i'll
have the deck open as we've been using
up to this point the second is i'm going
to have my terminal window also
available and let me bring that over so
you can actually see this and the
terminal window is actually running git
bash as the software in the background
which you'll need to download and
install you can also run git batch
locally on your windows computer as well
and in addition i'll also have the
github repository that we're using for
simply learn and already set up and
ready to go all right so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
is create a local repository so let's go
ahead and do exactly that so the local
repository is going to reside in my
development folder that i have on my
local computer and for me to be able to
do that i need to create a drive in that
folder so i'm going to go ahead and
change the directory so i'm actually
going to be in that folder before i
actually create and make the new folder
so i'm going to go ahead and change
directory
and now i'm in the development directory
i'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and that's gone ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
i'm going to move my cursor so that i'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that i'm in the hello world
folder i can now initialize this folder
as a get repository
so i'm going to use the get command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here i have my hello
world folder that i've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called dot get
and we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt
in our folder so here is our hello world
folder and i'm going to go ahead and
using my text editor which happens to be
sublime
i'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there text hello world
and i'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if i go to my hello world folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt
file actually in the folder what's
interesting is if i select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and
select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can
go and actually add the readme file so
let's go ahead and say at git add so the
git command is add readme.txt
so that then adds that file into our
main
project and we want to then commit those
files into the main repositories history
and so to that do that we'll hit the the
get command commit and we'll do a
message
in that commit and this one will be
first
commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and i can change this so we
can go
hello get
git is a very popular
version control
solution
and we'll
we'll save that
now what we can do is we can actually go
and see if we have made differences to
the readme text so to do that we'll use
the diff command for get so we do get
def
and it gives us two
releases the first is what the original
text was which is hello world and then
what we have afterwards is what is now
the new text in green which is replace
the original text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on github we already have one and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from github with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do dash and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we'll put in our username that we use
for
github in this instance we're using the
simply learn
dash
github account name
and under the github account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
world
and what we want to do is connect the
local github account with the remote
helloworld.getaccount
and we do that by using this command
from get which is our remote connection
and so let's go ahead and type that in
open this up so we can see the whole
thing so we can type in get
remote
add
origin
https
backslash backslash
github
dot com
slash
simply learn
dash github and you have to get this
typed in correctly when you're typing in
the location hello dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit get push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote github so i'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select git remote add
origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github
simply
learn
dash
github
slash
hello
dash world dot
get oh we actually have already
connected so we're connected to that
successfully and now we're going to push
the master
gish so get
push
origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to github now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and fork a project from github and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the
fork tool that's actually available on
github let me show you where that is
located and
here is our branching tool it's actually
changed more recently with a new ui
interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the fork's new http url address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now i'm
actually logged in with the default
primary account for this project so i
can't actually fault the project as i'm
working on the main branch however if i
come in with a separate id and here i am
i have a different id and so i'm
actually pretending i'm somebody else i
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
uh created the fork
so you want to say clone or download
with this and so this is the
i select
actually give me the web address i can
actually show you what that looks like
i'll open up my text editor
which doesn't correct
i guess that is correct so i'm going to
copy that
and
i can fork the project locally and clone
it locally i can change the directory so
i can create a new directory that i'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that folder so i
can now actually have multiple versions
of the same code running on my computer
i can then go into the forked content
and use the patchwork command
to actually
so i can create a copy of
that
code that we've just created when we
call it that's a clone and we can create
a new folder that we're actually putting
the work in and we could for whatever
reason we wanted to we could call this
where folder patchwork and that would be
uh maybe a new feature and then we can
then paste in the url of the new uh
directory that has the forked work in it
and now at this point we've now pulled
in and created a clone of the original
content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in
that separate branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
and we will do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
github name or by email address or by
their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes emerged into the master
branch now to do that you would create a
folder and then that folder in this
instance would be called test we would
then move our cursor into the folder
called test and then initialize that
folder so let's go ahead and do that so
let's call create a new folder and we're
going to first of all change our root
folder and we're going to go to
development
and we're going to create a new folder
we'll call it test and we're going to
move into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're gonna do file save as and
this one's gonna be test
two
and now we're gonna commit those files
okay add
that hit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git
commit
dash m
files
committed
make sure i'm in the right folder here i
don't think i was
and now that i'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and
commit
and it's gone ahead and edit those files
and so we can see the two files that
were created have been added into the
master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch
and call this one git
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as
we'll call this one
test3.txt
and we'll go ahead and add
that file
to git
add
test3.txt
and
we're going to move from the master
branch to the test branch
git
check out
test underscore
branch
i switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the text in that
branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git
merge test underscore
branch
and it's well we've already updated
everything so that's good so otherwise
it would tell us what we would be
merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from master branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore
branch
and we can modify
the files the test3 file that we took
out
and pull that file up
and we can
now
what if i
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in
and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and
obviously it's the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
the work is kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future
so let's switch to it back to our test
branch
which i think we're actually on we're
going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into
our branch that we're working on
so we're going to go and select
get
add
dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit
dash
a
dash m
adding
two new
files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch then to our master
branch we want to rebase the master
so we do get rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
we can go
get
checkout
master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then
continue through and rebase the test
branch and then list all the files that
are all in the same area
so let's go
get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
welcome to git commands my name is
chidanand and i am with the simplylearn
team i am going to cover few essential
git commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it i begin by
installing a git bash on the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once i'm done with configuring the
git client i'm going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once i'm
happy with my local changes i'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration i plan to use
github.com which is a cloud hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually i
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the git distributed version control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed version control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before i jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like windows
all flavors of windows linux mac os and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and gitlab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i will register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
over wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it onto my account within my git
server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that i
find as a gui tool i don't need this gui
client i need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0
and this is a 64-bit version for windows
so i've got that downloaded let me go
ahead and find it and install this exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me i'm not going to make any changes
here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
now i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say again
launch git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get
version it sounds good say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands
everything looks good so i ended up
installing the git bash i can go ahead
with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using the simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular user name of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id
that i would be setting up git to work
with all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initializes an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects there's references a bunch of
stuff that is there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here when i was in the
folder the repository did not have
anything after this now when i say git
in it there is something called as a
master that shows up so typically what
happens is whenever a git repository is
created for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the get in it and
then i'm not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so command
to add that is called git add i can
specify either the name of the file or i
can give a while character saying git
add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a git commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
all right i run the git status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit id or the
commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with a message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest comment that
is there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i will create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go ahead and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server
so let me go back to my server and
refresh this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text if at all i
see the commits there seem to be two
comments this is my first comment this
is my second comment and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit this is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify
the email id using which i'm going to
connect to or i need to create the keys
for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys
so i have logged in to github using my
credentials and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i would click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say get
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh all right so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that i create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server i will
create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server all right i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
report this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt some text file i'm going to
put in here yes definitely you will not
find that file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i don't get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file
onto the repository do you want to track
this file yes i definitely want to track
this file let me also commit my change
to the file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server
the origin is already set for me i don't
really need to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say get
push to be on the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all you
are creating a local repository you can
get into any of the folder which is not
a git repository and run this command
whenever you run this command a magical
folder by name dot kit gets created in
the folder and from that time onwards
git will start tracking any changes that
happen to that particular folder it also
creates a new repository and a branch by
default the branch that is created is
called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message get
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all status of the files
will be obtained using the git status
command git log will show you all the
commit history with the latest history
or the latest commit showing up on top
git add remote origin this command is
used whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen u origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the url of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of get
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the chain that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two comments but possibly i want
to club them together along with some
other changes because whatever changes i
did did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
commits but a soft would ensure that the
file changes that were done as a part of
these two comments would still exist a
full remain so the command for that is
git reset hyphen f and soft which is the
snapshot that i want to get back to if
this is the commit that i want to get
back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the chip that
were there as a part of c4 and c5 if at
all you do a git status
if you see the changes that were part of
c4 were some changes to m1 and m2 and c5
a new file got m4 got added if what i do
a git status
you would see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe i'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
also get
commit hyphen m
c for
history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was the part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and it is
not being pushed to the repository take
this scenario wherein let's say i have a
git server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all this c2 and c3 and
get into c4 and has pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
developer 1 wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and were planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the git
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest comment so if at all i see
the contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the get revert
command so git revert
and the commit id whatever i want to
revert so if i want to revert this
i copy this particular commit id
and bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was it as a part of this commit
actually is getting rid of this commit
c3 so if at all i see my files here
there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space however in git you just
create a very very lightweight mobile
pointer whenever you create a branch
there is no folder or no copy of the
repository that is created in short the
branches are very very inexpensive and
great so go ahead and create any number
of branches that you need however once
you create your branches do all the work
relating to that branch in that specific
branch and once you've completed your
task go ahead and merge your branches
back into your base branch and then
delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo
and then i'm going to create a new
folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any files in
it so let me create a few files on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just see
two files in it so let me go ahead and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first comment
so if i do a gig log
i see only one comment and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if i do
a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is get check out
plr branch i've actually switched into
bangalore branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because i've
created a branch from my base branch
which is a master branch and when i
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch so
i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put down the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address.txt so i say notepad
address dot text
we'll see simply learn
angular office
say located in
some address
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.text which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is gate
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to git
git check out master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you're in the
master branch the file that was there in
the bangalore branch which was called
the
address.txt didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to git
checkout bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i am switching to bangalore
branch i see this address dot text when
i go back to my master branch i don't
say this bangalore branch
contents which is the address.txt
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this is the name of the
repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push
hyphen u origin master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch it looks good
it says new bunch master is created so
if i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents that is
employees.txt and name.txt
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bangalore branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address dot text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by merging i would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangalore branch to come back
into my master branch so if i go to
click
checkout background branch i see this
attach.tech this is there only as a part
of bangalore branch now assuming that
i'm done with the changes from the
banner branch i want to get those
changes back into my master so let me
come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangle branch changes and
where will it merge it will merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
would see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
all right so there is only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the pack
lunch comment
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well
gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches
the branches master even if i'm in
master brands i should see this address
dot text that is there even if i'm in
the bangalore branch the content is all
same because we must these two branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch and i'm presently
in the master branch so i can go ahead
and delete the other branch so get
branch hyphen d bangle branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen way
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we've done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push this changes
so that the branch gets deleted from the
server as well the command to do that is
get
push
origin hyphen iphone delete
and the name of the branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish of your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch today we're going
to deep dive into what jenkins is and
how it improves your devops continuous
integration environments
so this is what we're going to be
covering in this session we're going to
cover what life is like before using
jenkins and the issues that jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your devops team then
specifically we'll deep dive into
features of jenkins and the jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before jenkins
let's see this scenario i think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
developer may be based in india you may
have another developer that's based in
the philippines and you may have another
team lead that's based in the uk and
another development team that's based in
north america so you're all working at
different times and you have different
amounts of code going into the code
repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with
just a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other
so let's jump into jenkins and see what
jenkins is and how it can address these
problems
so jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment
so there are two ways in which you can
do continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous
so the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created and that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to commit
our changes into our source code but we
can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification services into the build
environment so you're always running
cycles to test against your code this is
the power that jenkins provides in
continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository
the code that you're working on and then
you'll be able to then at any time
submit the code that you're working on
into a continuous integration server and
the goal of that continuous integration
server is that it actually goes ahead
and validates and passes any tests that
a tester may have created
now if on the continuous integration
server a test isn't passed then that
code gets sent back to the developer and
the developer can then make the changes
it allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all the
tests locally on their computer write
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service up
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be beyond just the standard ci test
so maybe there's a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with and maven and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environment and create your releases
very quickly so buildbots also written
in python and it does support parallel
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on java
projects that need to be built and test
then apache gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the java projects easier
for you to be able to test with api
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create a versioning of
your code is github and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by microsoft if you
are storing your projects in github then
you'll be able to use travis continuous
integration or travis ci and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects
and so finally we're covering jenkins
and jenkins is a central tool for
automation for all of your projects now
when you're working with jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called hudson hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became jenkins and it was
acquired by oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that oracle may potentially go with
hudson and so they created a hard fork
of hudson that they renamed jenkins and
jenkins has now become that open source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your ci
environment
so let's jump into some of those really
great features are available in jenkins
so jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as i mentioned for
the easy installation jenkins is a
self-contained java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including windows mac
os and unix you even run it on linux it
really isn't too bad to set up it used
to be much harder than it is today the
setup process has really improved the
web interface makes it really easy for
you to check for any errors in addition
you have great built-in help one of the
things that makes tools like jenkins
really powerful for developers and
continuous integration teams and your
devops teams as a whole when you have
plug-ins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plug-in architecture
jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure jenkins to fit in your
environment is almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending jenkins not creating a
custom version of jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core foundation the
distribution and the nature of jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your ci environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops
so let's jump into the standard jenkins
pipeline so when you're doing
development you start off and you're
coding away on your computer the first
thing you have to do when you're working
in the jenkins pipeline is to actually
commit your code now as a developer this
is something that you're already doing
or at least you should be doing you're
committing your code to a git server um
or to an svn server or a similar type of
service so in this instance you'll be
using jenkins as the place for you to
commit your code
jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the jenkins environment assuming
everything passed the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
jenkins
and finally again ready to deploy or
deliver your code to a production
environment jenkins is going to be the
tool that helps you with your server
environment to be able to deploy your
code to the production environment and
the result is that you're able to move
from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or go
through a nightly build you're looking
at being able to commit your code and go
through this testing process and release
process continuously as an example
companies etsy will release up to 50
different versions of their website
every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within jenkins that allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
server such as maven to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that it feedback is sent
right back to the developers so that
they can then change their code so that
the build environment can run
effectively
the final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
groups can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how jenkins can be
extended with plug-ins maven and
selenium are just two very popular
examples of how you can extend the
jenkins environment the goal to go
through this whole process again is an
automated process is to get your code
from the developer to the production
server as quickly as possible have it
fully tested and have no errors so it's
probably important at this point to
mention uh one piece of information
around the jenkins environment that if
you have different code builds that need
to be managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of jenkins for that to be able
to happen
so let's talk a little bit about the
master slave architecture within jenkins
so what we have here is an overview of
the master slave architecture within
jenkins on the left-hand side is the
remote source code repository and that
remote source code repository could be
github or it could be
team foundation services or the new
azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that master
environment can then push out to
multiple other jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario over the
last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as tesla
where they are creating uh software to
manage their cars we see the same thing
with companies such as general motors
with their onstar program and ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities enhancements to be added to
the core software so bosch is a company
that specifically ran into this problem
and their challenge was that they wanted
to be able to streamline the
increasingly complex automotive software
by adopting continuous integration and
continuous delivery best practices with
the goal of being able to delight and
exceed the customer expectations of the
end user so bosch has actually used
cloudbees which is the enterprise
jenkins environment so to be able to
reduce the number of manual steps such
as building deploying and testing bosch
has introduced the use of cloud b's from
jenkins and this is part of the
enterprise jenkins platform has
significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software developments cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment
now the results have been tangible
previously it took three days before a
build process could be done and now it's
taken that same three-day process and
reduced it to less than three hours that
is significant large-scale deployments
are now kept on track and have expert
support and there is clear visibility
and transparency across the whole
operations through using the jenkins
tools
jenkins is a web application that is
written in java and there are various
ways in which you can use and install
jenkins i have listed popular three
mechanisms in which jenkins is usually
installed on any system the topmost one
is as a windows or a linux based
services so if at all you have windows
like the way i have and i'm going to use
this mechanism for this demo so i would
download a msi installer that is
specific to jenkins and install this
service so whenever i install it as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warp file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt
differently on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a ctrl c
and then bring down this prompt and your
jenkins server would be down other older
versions of jenkins were run popularly
using this way in which you already have
a java based web server running up and
running so you kind of drop in this war
file into the root folder or the httpd
root folder of your web server so
jenkins would explode and kind of bring
up your application all user credentials
or user administration is all taken care
of by the apache or the tomcat server or
the web server on which jenkins is
running this was a very older way of
running but still some people use it
because if they don't want to maintain
two servers if they already have a java
web server which it's being nicely
maintained and backed up jenkins can run
attached to it all right so either ways
it doesn't matter however you're going
to bring up your jenkins instance the
way we're going to operate jenkins is
all going to be very very same or
similar one with the subtle changes in
terms of user administration if at all
you're launching it through any other
web server which will take care of the
user administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that's written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set this environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into those environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c column program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version all
right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if i told i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container wherein
you know you can launch jenkins as a
container but i'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sequel and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation okay so what typically
happens once the jenkins installation
gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
alright so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station
so as a part of the installation it just
asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plug-ins so if you
see
there is
a whole lot of plug-ins which are bare
essential plug-ins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail and these plugins are all
you know on available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate in all the
effort that has gone into the ui bottom
line it was a little hard to you know
wrap your head around it but once you
start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed in cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary uh
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for jenkins server so you can
specify the smtp server details of your
company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configurations that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your
you know your gmail account in case you
want to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
cans okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it get if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available
here i don't want to choose any of this
i don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some buildings tray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i've not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a time stamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go
here okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin for doing that so i get into
manage jenkins and manage plug-in
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role-based plug-in so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
say search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and
i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group
so i would create a role called
developer typically the jenkins instance
or the ca instance are kind of owned up
or controlled by qa guys so qr guys
would need to provide some sort of you
know limited access to developers so
that's why i'm creating a role called
developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
or check you know have read-only access
to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what am
i doing i'm just creating a global role
called developer and i'm giving him very
very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here house configure
management's manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular rule so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
rule and i would go ahead and save my
changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see a mix of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plugin that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect jenkins build you can build
a job on jenkins and push it to sonar
cube and get sonar cube to run analysis
on that and get back the results in
jenkins all of these works very well
because of the plugins now with that let
me connect our jenkins instance to
github i already have very very simple
java repository up on my github instance
so let me connect jenkins to this
particular github instance and pull out
a job that is put up there all right so
this is my very very simple uh you know
repository that is there called hello
java
and this is what is there in the repo
there is a hello hello.java application
that is here or a simple class file that
is there it's got just one line of
system.out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the
url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
stps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file i'm
keeping the source code very very simple
it's just a java file how do i build my
java file how do i compile my java file
i just say java c and the name of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job let it be a
freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from
but all right that sounds good but what
is the username and password so i'll
have to specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it will compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and it can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application
it contains a bunch of things and what
is important is just the index.jsp it
just contains an html file that is there
as a part of this web application so
from a perspective of requirements now
since i'm going to connect jenkins with
this particular repository git we
already have that set we only need two
other things one is maven because
jenkins will use maven so in order to
use maven jenkins would have to have a
maven installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files binary zip files and rkf files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is one open
source build tool so you'll have to set
in a few configurations and set up the
path so mvn hyphen iphone version if i
specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo
empty home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2home variable to the directory where
your unzipped jmi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is the tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our
jenkins server running on port 8080 we
cannot let tomcat run on the same port
there will be a port clash so what i've
done i have configured tomcat to use a
different port so if i go to this
configuration file here there is a
server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081 so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to tomcat users.xml file
here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this freestyle job that's
good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy
https url
okay that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so a simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file okay so mvn package is the
target package is the target so when
whenever i run this package it kind of
creates it it builds it it tests it and
then creates a package
so this is all that is required maybe
let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built
now i need to grab this particular war
file and then i would need to deploy it
into tomcat server
again i would need a small plug-in to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i would go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm going to just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now if this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that'll
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me okay what is the context path
context path is nothing but just the
name of an application that you know
under which it will get deployed into
the tomcat server i will just say mvn
web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential
jenkins credential the username is
deployer
and the password is
replier
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is a min
web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the uh jenkins instance and then it
was pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1
now for this demo i'm running everything
locally on my system but assuming that
you know this particular tomcat instance
was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you got to
go and change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven so let's step deeper into what
docker actually is so docker is a tool
which is used to automate the deployment
of applications in a lightweight
container so the application can work
efficiently in different environments
now it's important to note the container
is actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
hardware the containers are maintained
in isolated environments they're highly
productive and they're quick and easy to
configure so let's take an example of
what docker is by using a house that may
be rented for someone using airbnb
so in the house there are three rooms
and only one cupboard and kitchen and
the problem we have is that none of the
guests are really ready to share the
cupboard and kitchen because every
individual has a different preference
when it comes to how the cupboard should
be stocked and how the kitchen should be
used this is very similar to how we run
software applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails
perfect and flask and you may want to
have them running for different
applications for different situations
this is where docker will help you run
the applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space could also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see that docker has a client
server relationship there is a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that docker client
relationship is done through a rest api
and this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api
so we look here in the animation we see
that the docker client is constantly
communicating back to the server
information about the infrastructure and
it's using this rest api as that
communication channel the docker server
then would check out the requests and
the interaction necessary for it to be
the docker daemon which runs on the
server itself will then check out the
interaction and the necessary operating
system pieces needed to be able to run
the container okay so that's just an
overview of the docker engine which is
probably where you're going to spend
most of your time but there are some
other components that form the
infrastructure for docker let's dig into
those a little bit deeper as well so
what we're going to do now is break out
the four main components that comprise
of the docker environment the four
components are as follows the docker
client and server which we've already
done a deeper dive on docker images
docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you would take the script that you've
written about the docker container that
you defined and push it to the
repository and as you can imagine the
commands for that are also fairly simple
in terminal window you would write
docker push the image name any
associated tags and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again either a public or a private
repository so if we recap the docker
file creates a docker image that's using
the build commands a docker image then
contains all the information necessary
for you to be able to execute the
project using the docker image any user
can run the code in order to create a
docker container and once a docker image
is built it's uploaded to a registry or
to a docker hub where it can be shared
across your entire team and from the
docker hub users can get access to the
docker image and build their own new
containers
i'm anjali from simply learn and i'll be
taking you through the installation
process for docker so now let's begin
with the demo we'll be installing docker
on an ubuntu system so this is my system
i just opened the terminal so the first
thing you can start with is removing any
docker installation that you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch so this
is the command to do so sudo apt get
remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt-get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the suru
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull
an image from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a darker image which
is present on the docker hub docker hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working now we'll try out another
command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far so as you can see
here there are three hello world images
displayed and all of them are in exited
state so i did this demo previously too
which is why the two hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here and the first hello world
which has been created a minute ago is
the one we just did for this demo now as
you have probably noticed that all the
hello world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state and with that we come to
an end of our docker installation this
is matthew from simply learn in this
presentation we're going to go through a
number of key things we're going to
compare docker versus traditional
virtual machines and what are the
differences and why you want to choose
docker over a virtual environment we'll
go through the advantages of working
with docker and the structure and how
you would build out a docker environment
and during that structure we'll dig
through the components and the advanced
components within docker at the end of
the presentation we'll go through some
basic commands and then show you how
those basic commands can be used in a
live demo so with all that said let's
get started so let's first of all
compare docker with a traditional
virtual machine so here we have the
architecture on the left and right of a
traditional virtual machine versus a
darker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
now the bit up time for a virtual
machine is fairly slow in comparison to
the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used but you have
six gigs that are free you can't do
anything with it though that whole nine
gig has been allocated to that virtual
machine in contrast with docker if you
have nine gigs and six gigs becomes free
that free memory can then be reallocated
and reused across other containers used
within that docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment can
lead to instability and performance
issues whereas docker is designed to run
multiple containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more containers you run
in that hosted single docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that vm
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
the systems and again the actual boot up
time for a vm it just takes a long time
you took about minutes in contrast to
the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional vm
environment so docker itself is an os
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily
and the container itself is really just
a very lightweight package that has all
the instructions and dependencies such
as frameworks libraries bins etc all
within that container and that container
itself can then be moved from
environment to environment very easily
if we to look in our dev ops life cycle
the place where docker really shines is
in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really
you can use docker in multiple stages
within your devops cycle but it becomes
really valuable in the deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do rapid deployment and
you can do it really fast the
environment itself is highly portable
and was designed for that in mind the
efficiencies that you'll see will allow
you to run multiple docker containers in
a single environment as compared to more
traditional vm environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and i'm very
pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key talents for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how docker
actually works within your environment
so docker works there is a what's called
a docker engine the docker engine is
really comprised of two key elements you
have a server and a client and the
communication via the two is via a rest
api the server as you can imagine has
the instructions that are communicated
out to the client and instructs the
client on what to do the connection
between the client and the server the
communication is via a rest api
on older systems you can take advantage
of the docker toolbox which allows you
to go ahead and control the docker
engine the docker machine docker compose
and kitimatic so let's now go into what
the actual root components though of
docker r so let's have a look at those
key components there are four components
that we're going to go through we have
the docker client and server we have
docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one so let's look at the docker
clients and server first so the docker
clients and server is a command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac or command line on
your pc or linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest api
so you can do some communication such as
a docker pull command which would send
an instruction to the daemon which would
then form the interaction of pulling in
the correct components such as an image
or container or registry to the docker
client the docker demon itself is
actually a service which actually
performs all sorts of operating and
performance services and as you'd
imagine the docker daemon is constantly
listing across the rest api to see if it
needs to perform any specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process you what you want to do is
use the command dockered within your
docker daemon and that will start all of
your performances and then you have a
docker host which actually runs the
docker daemon and registry itself so now
let's look into the actual structure of
a docker image so a docker image itself
is a template which contains
instructions for the docker container
and that template is written with a
language called yaml and yaml stands for
yet another markup language it's very
easy to learn the docker image itself is
built within that yaml file and then
hosted as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers and you start with your base
layer which will typically have your
base image and this instance is your
base operating system such as ubuntu and
then you then have layer of dependencies
above that
this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your docker file so let's
let you go through and look at what one
of those in sets of instructions would
look like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto that base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the wrong commands so we can actually
then build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers at each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some call outs for the
components within a docket image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on write the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to keep improving the
efficiency within the actual system
itself all right so let's go on to item
number three which is the docker
registry so the docker registry itself
is the place where you would host and
distribute the different types of images
that you have created or you want to be
used within your environment the actual
repository itself is just a collection
of docker images and those docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and are very easily
stored and shared and what you can
actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see as we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifying how we actually
use it to actually create the actual
container itself one of things you can
do to as start off how you would manage
registry is you can actually use the
publicly accessible docker hub registry
which is available to anybody but you
can also create your own registry for
your own use internally the actual
registry that you create internally can
have both public and private images that
you create and this may be for various
reasons of how you structure your
environment the actual commands you
would use to actually connect to the
registry are both push and pull push is
to actually push a new container
environment that you've created from
your local manager node to the remote
registry and a pool allows you to pull a
new client that has been created and is
being shared so again full command and
it pulls and retrieves a docket image
from the docker registry and makes it
very easy for people to share different
images consistently across teams and a
push command allows you to take a new
command that you've created a new
container that you created and push it
to the registry whether it's docker hub
or whether it's your own private
registry and allow it to be shared
across your teams some key did you knows
in docker registry deleting a repository
is not a reversible action so if you
delete a repository it's gone so let's
go into the final stage here which is
the actual docker container itself so
the docker container itself um is an
executable package of applications and
its dependencies bundled together so it
gives all the instructions that you
would have for the solution that you're
looking to run it's actually really
lightweight and again this is because of
the redundancy that's built into how you
structure the container and the
container itself is then inherently also
extremely portable what's really good
about running a container though is that
it does run completely in isolation so
you're able to share it very easily from
grouped group and you are guaranteed
that even if you are running a container
it's not going to be impacted by any
host os peculiarities or unique setups
as you would have in a vm or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a docker
environment that can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm you
would have a defined amount of memory
for each vm environment the challenge
you start running into though is that
you can't share that memory whereas with
docker you can easily share the memory
for a single environment across multiple
containers
the actual container is built using
docket images and the command to
actually run those images is a run
command so let's actually go through a
basic structure of how you would run a
docket image so you go into terminal
window and you would write a docker run
redis and then it would run a container
called redis so we're gonna go in and if
you don't have the redis image locally
installed it will then pull it from the
registry then the new docker container
redis will be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within vms and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and you
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
get rid of those then you're doing great
so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two advanced components one is docker
compose and the second is docker swamp
so let's look at docker compose docker
compose is really designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
apache server with my sql database and
you need to create additional containers
to run additional services without the
need to start each one separately and
this is where you would write a set of
files using docker compose to be able to
help balance out that demand
so let's now look at docker swarm so
docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
docker environments within a single
platform
so what you actually are looking at
doing is within your docker swamp is
we're treating each node as a docker
demon and we're actually having an api
that's interacting with each of those
nodes there are two types of node that
you're going to be getting comfortable
working with one is the manager node and
the second is the worker node and as
you'd expect the manager node is the one
sending out the instructions to all of
the worker nodes but there is a two-way
communication that is happening the
communication allows for the manager
node to be able to manage the
instructions and then listen to receive
updates from the working node so if
anything happens within this environment
the imagine node can react and adjust
the architecture of the worker node so
it's always in sync it was really great
for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through what are some of the
basic commands you would use within
docker and once we've gone through all
these basic commands we'll actually show
you a demo of how you'd actually use
them as well so if we're going to go in
probably the first command is to install
docker and so if you have yam installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto your computer
to start the docker daemon as you want
to do system ctl start docker the
command to remove a docker image is
docker rmi and then the image id itself
and that's not the image name that's the
actual alphanumeric id number that you
want to grab the command line to
download a new image is docker pull and
then the name of the image you'd want to
pull and by default you're going to be
pulling from the docker default registry
that will then connect to your docker
daemon and download the images from that
registry khan the command line to run an
image is docker run and then the image
id
and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from docker hub then
we would have a docker pull and then the
image name and colon its tag
to pull build an image from a docker
file you would do docker build dash t
and then the image name and colon tag to
shut down the container you do docker
stop container id the access for running
a container is docker exec it container
id bash
so we've gone through all the different
commands but let's actually see how they
would actually look and we're going to
go ahead and do a demo so welcome to
this demo where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we have outlined in the
presentation for docker
first is just to list all of the docket
images that we have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
let's go ahead and pull a docker image
so to do that we'll we'll go ahead and
type sudo
docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to
select pull
and then the name of the image that we
want to pull which is going to be my
sequel
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest my sequel
command my sql image that we have so
it's now go ahead and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there
once that's done what we're going to go
ahead and do is we'll actually
run the docking container and create a
new container using the image that we
just downloaded but we have to wait for
this to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run
dash
d
p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon 80
and then put in my sql
colon
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token and that shows
our new docker container has been
created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do
sudo docker
ps
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do ps
dash a
and yes there we are we can see that we
do have our new container my sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago but
it's in the exit mode so what we have to
do is we have to change that status so
it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
flash
and
that's now going to be in the root and
we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the document containers we
should see it is now
an active container
sudo docker
start
and then we'll start the
scene
and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is check list of
images that we have
and to sudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed and what we want
to do is delete my sql and to do that
we're going to type in
sudo docker rm-f
image
mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image now there's no such image oh
okay so what we actually have to do is
we have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
it's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id as well
however if an image is running
and active we have to kill that image
first so we'll go ahead and we're going
to select the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to do
so we do sudo darker kill
and kill sl and that will kill the
container
and now
we'll see that the container has gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image going
with image id but boom
easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
oh good so here we are we've listed all
of the uh
and they're all gone so let's go into
the next exercise final exercise which
is to actually
create a batch image
now we're gonna do a batch http image so
let's go ahead and write that out so
it's gonna be docker
run
it
dash dash
name
white
that's going to be the name of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80 dash v
open quotes
dollar sign pwd
close quotes
colon
slash usr
slash local
slash
apache2
slash htdocs
slash
httpd
semicolon 2.4
we'll run that
put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what ports are
running so let's do sudo images and see
which ports are being used because it's
either the the port or the name um
hasn't been put in correctly so sudo
docker images
ps
pseudo docker
ps dash a
and
yep
let's port 80 there
so we'll clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila here we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser
and we'll type in
as soon as firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running today we're going to cover
what is a docker container why you would
want to consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you actually creating virtual
machines but those virtual machines
actually are now sitting within a
hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java a second container is running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all running just
fine within the docker engine and
sitting on top of a host os which could
be linux it really could be any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a test and now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times and this is where it
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environment if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the jboss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from the challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docker container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is darker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment
from one group to the next so let's kind
of dig into that architecture so you
understand why docker runs effectively
so the docker architecture itself is
built up of two key elements there is
the docker client and then there is a
rest api connection to a docker daemon
which actually hosts the entire
environment within the docker host and
the docker daemon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest api and that sends
command line to the docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with darker the docker
demo then checks the request against um
the docker components and then performs
the service that you're requesting now
the docker image itself all it really is
a collection of instructions used to
create a container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the actual
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
solutions the actual docker registry
itself is an environment for being able
to host and distribute different docker
images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in
the container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer
intended what's interesting though is
the actual applications then will run in
isolation so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
the actual folder itself is much smaller
it's very secure highly portable and the
boot up time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the dock image
you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other docker images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using nginx as our registry and
we can actually then pull the image down
to our test environment on our local
machine so we're actually running the
container within our docker application
on a local machine we're able to then
have the image run exactly as it would
in production and then you can actually
use the run command to actually use the
docker image on your local machine so
just a you know a few interesting
tidbits about the docking container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the docker image layers
called the container layout each
container has a separate read write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon the particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why would
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jboss at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy to share the containers amongst
your teams whether it's a developer
whether it's a tester whether it's
somebody on your operations environment
it's really easy to share those
containers amongst your entire team
different data volumes can be easily
reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask us you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we're going to end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a doctor container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands and the demo that we're going
to do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stop working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac and we're going to go ahead
and the first thing we want to do is see
what our docker image lists are so we
can go sudo docker images and this will
give us well first we'll enter in our
password so let's go enter that in and
this one that gives a list of our docker
images and here are the docker images
that have already been created in the
system and we can actually go ahead and
actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and open up this window a little
bit more but this will show you the
actual processes and the containers that
we actually have and so on the far left
hand side you see under names we have
learn simply learn the underscore cool
these are all just different ones that
we've been working on so let's go ahead
and create a docker image so i'm going
to do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash p
0.0.0.0
go on 80 column 80
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the container that we've
just created and we can go ahead and we
can check to make sure that the
container actually is present so we're
going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
sound there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exit state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and this lists all the
containers that i have running on my
machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit state and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created
and it's been running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this to scrub this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so we do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo
docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my docker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and
yep
it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right
let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of the
container that we actually have
so pseudo docker
kill
oh we're going to list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo darker
kill
simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
today we're going to dig into docker
swarm so what we're going to do in this
session is we're going to go through
what a docker and docker container is
and why you'd want to use it we'll then
break out what are the characteristics
and structure of a docker swarm
environment and then finally we'll go
through and do a demo using actual code
in the command line interface to
actually run and build out the main
functions and commands that you would
use for a docker swarm environment so
with that said let's get started so
docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
advantage when you're working with
docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code without having to have
the significant overhead that you would
normally have with virtualization so one
of the characteristics you have with
docker is that you can actually run
multiple docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
docker swarm and a docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a docker swarm is so a
docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule multiple docker nodes so really
two or more docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of docker
nodes in a single swarm
each node itself is actually a docker
daemon and that demon is able to
interact with the docker api and have
all the benefits of being a full docker
environment one of the other advantages
you have is that the each docker
container within the swarm can then be
deployed and managed but as a node in
that entire clustered environment so
what we have here is a breakdown of the
five key elements within a docker
environment you have the docker
container you have the daemon the docker
images and the docker client and docker
registry so the docker game itself is
what does all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers so
if we look here here we have set up an
environment where we have three docket
containers being run with docker and
what we want to be able to do is it be
able to interact with the environment
because what would happen if we actually
have something change in our environment
so we have the environment set up as a
docker swarm and one of our containers
fails what we're able to do is use the
swarm to be able to correct that failure
so the docker swarm manager is able to
come in and reschedule containers and as
you would imagine the actual swarm note
has full backups and full redundancy for
any kind of failures that would happen
and we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual docker swarm
itself so a key feature for docker swarm
is that it is fully decentralized which
means that it makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment as you would expect as
well is that the communication that
happens between the manager and client
nodes within the swarm is highly secure
and of course this is really just a
fundamental that you should have for any
kind of solution but it is good to know
that docker swarm has that built in
there is also auto load balancing within
your environment you can actually script
that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then roll back task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so if say
something that does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different services
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your service so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swan we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual uh
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simply learn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the working nodes
as you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sequel environment then
the worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from
third-party solutions that you may want
to create so one of the things that's a
really a big advantage with having a
swarm is that once you've actually
created the swarm any of the services
and that you create can be accessed by
any node of the same cluster one of the
things you do have to do though is you
have to specify what container image
that you're going to use when you're
creating a new service and you can do
that either through a centralized docker
hub environment or through your own
private docker hub environment one of
the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either global or replicated a global
service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey is it a
service and task the same thing no
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really
similar in concept to worker nodes in
which they have the capability of a
manager but they are dependent on that
single primary manager to be able to
provide the right instructions and for
services and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their ip address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check for when to ask them in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager note to
the work note so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build right so with
that said let's go ahead and we're going
to do a demo so we're going to go ahead
and do a demo and showing how you can
run docker swarm for this you'll need to
have both a virtual environment running
your manager and your working
environment so here we have our worker
and
here we have our manager so we're just
going to open up terminal window and
we're going to go into the manager for
terminal window so the following command
here is used to initialize docker swan
which is going to type this in so sudo
docker swarm init
and we put the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and opening our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and we want
to be able to highlight is the specific
token which identifies the docker swarm
environment and this is our token right
here so we're going to copy that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied um as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swamp and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did that in the wrong
area so we're on the right pseudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the worker virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine image from docker.com
it takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the docking
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker
paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we're gonna make the mode global and
that way the service is available across
all of the swarm
so we're just gonna execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services are running and
if we go back to the worker mode and we
run sudo docker ps again and there we
are now we see that we have the hello
world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of alpine and we also
have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the following command which
is pseudo docker swamp leave dash dash
force
and that will force the node to leave
the swarm today we're going to cover
docker compose so in this session what
we're going to do is we're going to go
through what docker is and then by
extension what docker compose is and how
it improves the performance of docker
what the benefits of working with docker
compose is we are going to cover as well
what the difference between docker
compose and docker swarm is because the
two products are similar but they have
two different types of job and at the
end of this presentation we'll take you
through some basic commands that allow
you to get up and running working with
docker and docker compose finally after
this presentation we'll do a brief demo
that allows you to get up and running
using some of these commands to do your
own docker compose environment so let's
get started with docker compose so first
of all we have to kind of cover what
docker is so docker has come as an
evolution of technologies that started
with virtual machines vm machines and a
vm machine allows you to run a complete
operating system and complete operating
system and its environment on your own
computer in your own operating system
without it interfering the problem was
is that it's very heavy and complex and
in contrast docker is a much more
lightweight and more flexible
environment that you can automate with
scripts so we have to remember that the
container itself is just software and it
has dependencies that run within that
application that are managed by docker
so we have a look at the way dockers
broke now first of all we have the
docker image and we have the docker
image created by a docker file and the
docker file is a text-based script and
that text file within file actually has
all the commands that allow you to run
the appropriate technologies within the
docker image so the docker image allows
you to be able to have a wide group of
people consistently run the same
environment and if you want to be able
to share that docker image effectively
you would do so by uploading to docker
hub and docker hub can be available
either publicly uh through the the
public docker hub website or you can
actually set up your own private
enterprise docker hub to share your own
images across your own network and then
from docker hub people can then pull
their own docker image and build new
containers that are consistent on the
original docker container that you
created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example this
might be like a web server that is using
a database but the database may be in
one container and the web server may be
in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar um
scenario but how would you do this with
doc app so by using just docker itself
it's actually very difficult to do this
you can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so
myntra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you go to mentor with your web browser
and
on that website you would go through a
number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog
you'd have your checkout application
server and you go through the typical
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know have
an account database you'd have a product
database different checkout processes
and these would all be run behind the
scenes and each of these can be
considered a micro service so the more
microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting language and
then finally in docket compose as a user
you can actually go and and trigger all
your services within the containers to
start with a single command as you can
imagine this dramatically reduces the
amount of work that you as a developer
have to do so let's take an example of
if you're running a container one with a
ninjx server and one with the redis
database uh you can create a yaml docker
compose file that actually has the
instructions on the containers needed to
build out both environments and then you
can run each of those environments
separately but have them connected as a
single service so the benefits of duck
and compose is that you have a single
host deployment environment you can run
this all on one piece of hardware you
can have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docket compose isn't it
similar in concept to docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose so docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part having a single host which is maybe
your development pc with docker swarm it
also allows you to create multiple
containers however you have to manage
those multiple containers on multiple
hosts which makes a lot of sense if
you're running an operations environment
but not so much if you're doing a
development environment and docker
compose is scripted with yaml which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swarm doesn't have a
scripting technology like yaml so it's a
little bit harder to work with so what
we have here is just some basic commands
that allow you to get up and started
working with docker compose and in our
next demo we're actually going to take
you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use docker compose
um the first thing you want to do is
check that you have docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in docker you'll be able
to see now that we have docker installed
if you don't have dock installed go
ahead and install docker you can go to
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have docker
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and select for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has uh
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you copy the correct command
line so there's a couple command lines
you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in it's going to go ahead and
download all of the files for compose it
takes a while but
we have to get another file so while
it's downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick there's a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary and once you've done
that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using variable uh
content at the moment let's just go
ahead and clear the screen and now what
we're going to do is create a folder
where we're actually going to install
the ammo file that will have the
instructions for our docker component
environment so we're moving the cursor
to the desktop and on the desktop we're
going to create a new folder and uh
using the mkdirf command and we'll call
this one docker
f for file and then we'll move the
cursor into that new folder by using cd
command and now we are in the folder
called docker compose f and you can go
look at your desktop and you'll see it's
there and now you want to select um
pound touch docker dash compose dot yml
and that'll actually create the new yaml
file for you and you can use the ls list
command ls docker dash compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and
hit return and that allows to go in and
edit the file so now i'm in the editor
and i'm going to write some instructions
um so i'm i'm going to put a couple of
mistakes in these instructions so we can
see how dr pose catches those mistakes
um so but most of this is going to be
fairly correct so you can just type this
out so we're going to start with
surfaces colon then we do web colon and
then we create image colon and we'll do
nitrix and then we'll do a database
colon and we call the image redis and so
what you can see because we have two
reference images we're actually calling
two different images two different
containers that will be created by
docker hub so what we're gonna do is uh
where we can actually show you um how
that's pulling in you can go to docker
hub and you can actually see the
references to the images that we've just
created so go to docohub which is hull
hub.docker.com and you'll see that uh
nijix redis those are the default names
for the images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're going to save those
files um in the docker image and we're
just going to do colon wq to exit this
screen save the text and this is going
to run our yaml file and you'll see the
two different error messages that will
come up so we can do cat docker dash
compose dot yml and here we have a
display of the text that we just wrote
and now let's go check the validity of
the file that we just created so we'll
do docker dash compose config and we
should get an error message and there we
are error message and the reason why we
have an error message is because the
spacing is not correct in the yaml file
itself so let's go to the actual yaml
file that we created let's go through
and we're going to use uh just the file
finder and you'll actually open up the
yaml file in your text editor your
favorite text editor and here we have um
the code that created it and that's use
the correct um spacing so that
everything is spaced out appropriately
in the image and so this is the spacing
that you'd expect to see a space a line
between surfaces and the first image and
the first image is a tab in and then it
referenced what the image is and let's
go ahead and clear the screen and we'll
see whether or not we've got that all
correct it click um this clear screen
and we're going to check that everything
is running correctly and we're seeing
we're still getting an error message and
the reason why we're getting another
error is that there's still a config
error in this the actual yaml file so
one of the things you have to do when
you're creating a yaml file for docker
composers you actually have to have the
appropriate version uh number in there
so what we have to do is we have to go
and find which is the appropriate
version and there are three major
versions one two and three depending on
the age of docker that you have
installed on your computer so if you
have the very latest version of docker
18 and newer you would put 3.7 as the
version number and what we're going to
do is we're going to just check on the
version that we have installed and so
just clear the screen and then we'll
just do docker version and what we have
is our version of docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose uh it's your main
docker environment and so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that version 17 should align with
version number 3.5 yep there we are
version 3.5 so what we want to do is go
back into a yaml file the very first
line that we want to put in above the
services is the version number and that
version number we're going to put in is
3.5 so we type in version version and we
put colon and then version number is in
brighton quotes and you save that and
now what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the
single line instruction to run both of
these uh
two images that we created because
everything is configured correctly for
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then press the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose up
dash d and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use sudo docker ps to actually list out
that all the processes that are running
right now and there we are we actually
see all of the images are running we
have the names the commands the images
and everything's up and running and if
we want to close both of those images we
can actually use a single line of
command as well and that command will be
sudo docker dash compose down and that
closes both of the images and we can see
that all the databases and the web
services images have been closed and
sudo.ps where she lists that there is
nothing running and that's how to use
docker compose in this session we're
going to cover what kubernetes is and
why you would want to be using it within
your devops team so let's get started
we're going to break up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening and why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to buying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have air issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balance
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive uh you can only install one
piece of software one service on one
piece of hardware so your hardware is
being massively under utilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability at much less
cost and this allows you to be able to
run multiple virtual machines on a
single piece of hardware the problem is
is that vms or for virtual machines are
not perfect either some of the
challenges you run with vms is that the
actual hardware and software need needed
to manage the vm environment can be
expensive there are security risks with
virtual with vms there are security
risks with vms there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming it can take a lot of
time and it can also get very expensive
so how about kubernetes well kubernetes
is a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
and this is largely because of the
legacy code
the legacy of kubernetes and where it
came from we'll talk about that in just
a moment but kubernetes is inherently
secure
virtual machines are not easily portable
now with that said they they are
technically portable they're just not
very easily portable whereas with
kubernetes it's working with docker
container solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a
virtual machine a few other areas that
we want to kind of highlight from
differences virtual machines use much
less isolation when building out the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does for instance with a virtual machine
you have to run hypervisor on top of the
os and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hierarchy so as we highlighted here our
vms are not as portable as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment it allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence uh kubernetes
is an open source platform that is
allows you to manage and deploy and
maintain groups of containers and the
container is something like docker and
if you're developing code you're
probably already using docker today
consider kubernetes as the tool that
manages multiple docker environments
together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
google board google borg it does exactly
what kubernetes and does today but
kubernetes was rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
microsoft azure aws google cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first it is highly
portable and is 100 open source code and
this means that you can actually go
ahead and contribute to this code
project if you want to through github uh
the ability to scale up the solution is
incredible um what's the the history of
kubernetes being part of a google
project for managing the google network
and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the
load balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud-first
environment um kubernetes swell is that
it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails kubernetes will detect
that failure and then either restart the
process kill the process or replace it
and then because of that you also have
automated rollouts and drawbacks in case
you need to be able to manage the state
of the environment and then finally uh
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes um that actually are running
on linux machines um outs that are
controlled by the master so let's kind
of go through some of these um areas so
if we look at the kubernetes master to
begin with
then we'll start with uh etc this is a
tool that allows for the configuration
of information and the management of
nodes within your cluster and one of the
key features that you'll find with all
of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the api server um and
what's interesting about the api server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with ssl
and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the uh the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas controller is the
management actually pushes out all of
the controls via the api server so let's
actually dig into um one of the actual
nodes themselves and there are three key
areas of the nodes one is the docker
environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in to an
indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way hi guys in today's video i am going
to show you how to install ubuntu on
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
platform used for deployment and
management of containers so let's get
started now the first step is to install
the necessary dependencies using two of
the commands first is sudo apt-get
update which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system cto enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
girl
[Music]
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key at
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo ch mode command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubedm cubectel and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that so this is going to take a few
minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that pseudo swap of
hyperlink
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm init
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so
moving forward the next step is to
deploy paths using the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the parts you have to
use the command sure cubic till get bots
there you can see the parts that have
been deployed hello and in this video
we're going to cover a common
conversation which is kubernetes versus
darker but before we jump into that i
want you to hit the subscribe button so
you get notified about new content as it
gets made available and if you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simplyland in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problem specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals uh to be able to allow
their product groups to be able to
easier more easily catch up to the scale
of their business so after going through
a number of solutions they ended up
coming up with a solution of having
kubernetes running their iot platform as
a service inside of amazon's aws cloud
service and what you'll see with both
these products they're very cloud
friendly but here we have bose and
kubernetes working together with aws to
be able to scale up and meet the demands
of their product catalog and so the
result is that we're able to increase
the number of non-production deployments
significantly by taking the number of
services from being large bulky surfaces
down to small micro services being able
to handle as many as 1250
plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so the problem is with
paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge um that uh paypal was uh
really being given is that they had
different architectures which resulted
in different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50 percent increase in availability for
being able to and add in additional time
for building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for paypal
now let's dig into kubernetes and docker
and so kubernetes is an open source uh
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're going to find
is that your argument for kubernetes
versus docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two
and the differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers so the the
difference and here is that kubernetes
is going to manage the entire
environment and then and that
environment consisting of pods and
inside of a pod you're going to have all
of your containers that you're working
on and those containers that can control
the services that actually power the
applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas a docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas doctor
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now i'm not going to
kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
it's if of the tools that you're going
to be using in your devops environment
it's it's not an easy setup for you to
use and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the the services
within its own containers what you'll
find is that most public cloud providers
will provide support for both kubernetes
and docker here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick to jump on and support kubernetes
uh but the reality is is that today
google amazon and many other providers
are having first level support for
kubernetes has just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
docker is fast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list hello and welcome
to simplyland today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're gonna do
a deep dive into the actual kubernetes
architecture itself and how kubernetes
runs and operates within your network
and then finally we're going to look at
some kubernetes use cases of how you can
actually apply best learnings that other
companies have used with kubernetes
we'll finish everything off with a demo
where we actually step through and use
some of the actual codes that you can
actually use to run uh from your
terminal window to actually activate
kubernetes itself so with that said
let's jump in so why kubernetes well
kubernetes is really being built from
allowing you to be able to have a more
reliable infrastructure the tool itself
is designed to manage the containers you
have within your network it's very
modular in architecture which allows it
to be very easy to be able to maintain
and to be able to scale and meet the
demands that your current customers are
offering you today the actual ability
for you to be able to deploy and update
software at scale is really at the heart
and center of kubernetes it's really one
of the reasons why kubernetes was
created was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers uh
within a data center and then finally uh
when you start working with kubernetes
really what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by google google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the
data structure and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they uh converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allowed for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security the
storage and the networking within those
containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done uh kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes uh
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit uh kubernetes and docker
often get connected with each other
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and docker is really famous
for creating the most popular uh
container management solution which is
called docker if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker
today so one of the things that
kubernetes is really really good at is
that it manages containers at scale just
massive volume of containers docker
swarm is docker's alternative to
kubernetes it's a tool that allows you
to also manage large number large
numbers of containers um there are
differences between the two of them and
right now without doubt the most popular
um open source solution out there is
kubernetes from google it just has a
massive community behind it and the
community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by google but google
has been great stuart and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you will be able to
set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment uh
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com youtube i mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to docker swamp which has lower fault
tolerance and and this really kind of
leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment dr swarm however is able to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set in
contrast uh load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine uh in a data center or
a virtual machine and when you're
setting up an environment on a cloud
environment such as microsoft azure or
google cloud or aws kubernetes will be
managing the containers within that node
so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
match the entire environment the actual
control of data within a cluster um it's
very very flexible within kubernetes you
can have local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture where you're not reliant on
a physical piece of hardware within your
data center and why that's important is
that it gives you the opportunity to
scale up your solutions much more
effectively so if you need to increase
the hard drive space you can do that
very easily from the cloud whereas local
hardware is a little bit harder to
manage great news kubernetes gives you
both options to be able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application that's within a container
and as mentioned earlier docker is the
most popular container solution out
there and again if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
will actually manage the containers that
you have within your nodes and so you
have a collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that part so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the ports
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes um do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
pods your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right-hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left-hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is uh
comprised of a number of key components
um again this is the tool that's going
to
manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the
etcd control manager scheduler api
server and the key four components are
etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules it's going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and the instructions here are to pull
down the correct container from the
docker images that you have within your
library the cubelet is going to manage
your containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml you'll pick
up yaml very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify sap ebay um and
of course uh some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a youtube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when new york times started working
out of their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that uh
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is they
treated the cloud hosted provider in the
same way as they would with a data
center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon let's start thinking them as
cloud first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as servers um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going to look through um and uh
we'll let you uh read through these but
uh we have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is you define a paused life cycle rather
than to create the pods directly we have
a selector which is an expression
matched label to filter specific
resources labels are key value pairs
that are attached to objects such as
parts and the key value pair or the
label can be filter organize and perform
operations on resources replication sets
define how many replicas of each pod
will be running and managed when you
want to either replace a pod when it
dies annotation is a label with much
larger data capacity a name is a
resource as it is identified volume is
the directory which data is accessible
to a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to a
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single ip address and dns name
by which the pods can be accessed so at
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
i'm going to take you through a video of
how to actually install kubernetes um
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
widely used platform for container
management the first step is to actually
install the necessary dependencies so
let's see if there's any updates first
so the first so to check if there's any
updates we use the command sudo app dash
get update we're entering our password
and this looks like it's going to take a
few minutes because we've got a few
updates that need to be running all
right we're done all right next we're
going to write sudo apt-get install dash
y apt dash transport https and this will
install all the dependencies we need to
actually start installing the solutions
needed for kubernetes all right that was
quick now we're going to put in the
docker dependency and the way we do that
is write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go typo correct that
quickly and put in y so for yes and we
continue and it's going to take a while
because we're going to download and
install docker off the internet and it's
quite a large installation now would be
a good time to go get a cover copy
because it'll take us about a minute to
get this all done once we actually have
docker installed we'll let you go ahead
and we'll start docker and enable docker
using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're using so
we're going to use sudo systemctl start
docker and sudo systemctl enable docker
this would be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to uh install the curl command and
then kuberlead cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt you can say yes
for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be sudo curl dash s and
then we have a long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
dash key dot gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go uh create my typo
there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of a folder so we do that
with sudo chmod
777 slash etc apt
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
then the following command db http
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
dash xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then a apt which is going to be down a
little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes.list and we'll save that and
then we can close out the notepad and go
back to the terminal window and let's
look and see if there are any updates
again so we're going to go ahead and run
apt-get update and it's going to run any
updates from what we've created and we
want to check what's in the folder and
so we do
cat slash accept
etc
apt sources.this dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to uh
install uh cubelet cubic cubic 2 and q
adm but first we're going to have to
initialize the master i'm going to show
you what an error you would get if you
were to install cubelet um and the other
files too quickly you get the following
error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubexo and kubernet cni and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen
a and now we're going to initialize the
master node and we're going to do that
with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the plot to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then we have a long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content.com koreos final master
documentation cube dash final dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating
mkdi dash p and then we have um dollar
sign home dash dot cube we'll create
that new directory and sudo cp dash i
and then the path will be uh etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo
chow n dollar sign open paren id dash u
close paren colon dollar sign brand id
slash dash g close paren dollar sign
home slash dot cube
config all right now we're going to go
ahead and deploy and uh let's see
oh yeah i think i have a typo in my
command here yep oh yeah i did have a
typo and so um i've got that incorrect
now so documentation is actually spelled
with a t not an s and then we're going
to go ahead and we're going to put in
the next
line which is pseudo cubic
cube ctl apply
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
parts that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by uh writing the
command sudo qbec ctcl get pods dash all
dash dash name spaces and it should list
all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we can use the command sudo you know
cubic tl get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
nginx as service and we're going to do
that with the command sudo cubex ctl run
dash dash image equals nginx and we're
going to put this into port 80 so it's
going to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80
environment or emv equals uh ubuntu
open quotes so domain equals cluster
close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx dash http and once
we've done this we will be able to then
run the command to actually see our
services and there'll be quite a few of
them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands um it it's worth going
through a few times to
get right um but uh once you actually
have um the uh kubernetes environment up
and running and managing your docker
environment and containers it's
extremely powerful we're going to take a
deep dive into the kubernetes
architecture so we're going to break out
the presentation into the following
areas we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you want to be
using it we're going to introduce the
actual architecture and provide an
overview of how it contains the
containers and the other components that
you'd have within the architecture we'll
also compare kubernetes with docker
swarm and one of the things that you
hear with kubernetes almost in the same
breath as docker and we have to be
careful not to confuse docker from a
container point of view and docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so compare the two of
those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by google out
of the google borg solution and then
open source by google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with docker then you're used to the
concept of a container and
you'll also know that containers and
cloud technologies tend to be almost
breathed in the same breath so the work
that you're doing with kubernetes is to
be able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points uh kubernetes
itself is an open source solution
originally developed by google but it is
available on most cloud platforms today
so aws google cloud microsoft azure all
of them support kubernetes and what
you'll find is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these
i think one of the big benefits of
kubernetes is its modularity is that it
really breaks down uh containers into
their smaller parts and once you do that
it becomes much more efficient for you
as an administrator to be able to manage
that entire entire environment the
reproductibility of kubernetes is
extremely high you can build our
infrastructures very quickly and have
them being able to manage and have
containers coming on and off and killed
and created to be able to help low
balance your entire environment and so
again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed by the master environment so you
have your cluster which is a collection
of servers that maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as ram cpu and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule uh
the activities of your network and then
you have the node which actually hosts
the actual docker virtual machine itself
um and be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail in the architecture later in
the presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
um containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital technologies
over the last uh 10 15 years so
before kubernetes
you had tools where you're either
running virtual machines or you're
running uh data centers that had to
maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions and
manages them for you so the solution to
this is the use of containers so uh you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know uh 15 20 years
ago you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center and more
recently you probably posted your code
to a virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're isolated
environments very easy for developers to
work in them but it's also really easy
for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step in and back and look at a
competing product to kubernetes which is
docker swarm now one of the things that
we have to remember is that uh docker um
containers which are extremely popular
um built by the company docker and made
open source and docker actually has
other products one of those other
products is docker swarm and docker
swarm is a tool that allows you to be
able to manage multiple containers so if
we look at some of the uh the benefits
of using docker swarm versus kubernetes
and one of the things that you'll find
is that both tools have strengths and
weaknesses but it's really good that
they're both out there because it helps
keep it really kind of justifies the
importance of having these kind of tools
so kubernetes was designed originally
from the ground up to be auto scaling
whereas docker swarm isn't the load
balancing is automatic on docker swan
whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for docker
swarm is really fast and easy i mean you
can be up and running within minutes
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's a when you compare the two docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with docker swarm its cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability kubernetes was designed for
by google to scale up and support google
cloud network infrastructure they both
allow you to be able to share
storage volumes with docker you can
actually do it with um any container uh
with uh that is managed by the docker
swamp whereas with kubernetes it manages
the storage with the pods and a product
can have multiple containers within it
but you can't take it down to the level
of the container interestingly
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface um for being able to control
and manage uh the environment the
reality however is that you're likely to
be using terminal uh to actually make
the controls and commands to control
your um either docker swarm or
kubernetes environment um it's great
that it has a gui and to get you started
but once you're up and running you're
gonna be using terminal window for those
fast quick administrative controls that
you need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at
it's extremely lightweight um it's um
allows you to have if you compare it to
like a virtual machine which is very
heavy it you know um kubernetes is
extremely lightweight and hardly uses
any resources at all interesting enough
though is that if you are looking at the
usage of cpu it's better to actually
take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so let's kind of pivot
and look at the software components as
compared to the hardware components so
the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container runs on linux so if you have
docker installed as a developer on your
machine it's actually running inside of
linux and that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of the things
that you'll find is that most data
centers and cloud providers now are
running predominantly on linux inside of
the um the the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a pod is
really just a group of containers
bundled together and um the kubernetes
scheduler and proxy server will then
actually manage what um how the pods are
actually pushed out uh into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of
manual management of pods if you have to
manage the deployment of them and you
that's simply taken away and it's
completely automated and the the final
area of software services is on ingress
and this is really the secure way of
being able to have communication from
outside of the cluster and passing of
information into that cluster and again
this is done securely through ssl layers
and allows you to ensure that security
is at the center of the work that you
have within your kubernetes environment
so let's dive now into the actual
architecture before we start looking at
a use case of how kubernetes is being
employed so kubernetes again is um we
looked at this uh diagram at the
beginning of the presentation and there
are really three key areas there's the
workstation where you develop your
commands and then you have your master
environment which uh controls the
scheduling the communication um and the
actual
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node network and each
node has various pods so we like break
this down so the master node is the most
vital component with the master you have
four key controls you have etc
controller manager scheduler and api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the out the control schedule and api
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an api
server and again
this is all about security so we use
restful apis which can be packaged in
ssl to communicate back and forth um
across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
um at every single layer of extraction
uh the communication is secure the
schedule as the name would imply really
schedules um when tasks get sent out to
the actual nodes themselves the nodes
themselves are down nodes they just have
uh the applications um running on them
the master and the sperm is really doing
all of the work uh to make sure that
your entire network is running um
efficiently and then you have the api
server which has your rest commands and
the communication and back and forth
across your network that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so
a work is really a it's a combination of
containers and each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers uh
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together uh within each node um you
have uh docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your cubelet which is a
service for conveying information back
and forth to the service about the
actual health of the kubernetes node
itself and then finally you have the
proxy server and the proxy server is
able to manage the nodes the volumes the
the creation of new containers um and
actually helps pass the communicate the
health of the container back up to the
master to see whether or not the
container should be either killed stop
started or
updated so finally let's look at see
where kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have uh greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to delight
the customer and increase value to the
customer and enhance uh increased value
and revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running a complex
installations on people's desktops and
it was just really really difficult to
be able to manage their entire
infrastructure so they actually went and
pivoted to using kubernetes and this
allowed them to be able to be much more
scalable and expansive in the in the
management of their
infrastructure and as you can imagine
kubernetes was then hooked into their
entire existing system and has really
become a key part of the success that
blackrock is now experiencing of a very
stable infrastructure and the bottom
line is that blackrock is now able to
have confidence in their infrastructure
and be able to give that confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at offset i would like to cover the
basics of orchestration tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kuvernez architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or life cycle management
using some or the other kind of a tool
so that's where these orchestration
tools have become very very popular so
what kind of features that they provide
is you'll have to just let them know
what are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a one stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missiles there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubernetes just because of the reason
that both of them operate in the space
of container management they do
something very very similar to
containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exists when it comes to the types
of containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for docker swamp is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by docker container docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only docker containers docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration tool kubernetes on the
other hand can cater to any other types
of containers other than docker and
including docker as well so in case you
have your applications which have got
docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
over 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and communities putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high your
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the
powerfulness of auto scaling which is
provided by kubernetes and this
unfortunately does not exist in docker
swarm the other feature of load
balancing specifically application node
balancing so docker swarm gives you an
application level auto load balancing
however kubernetes gives you the
flexibility of manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for application load balancing
installation as i mentioned earlier
docker swarm is a loose cluster of
containers which are running on nodes it
is very easy to spin up a new node and
then connect them to a swarm and this
can be done in a very very loosely
coupled way where you can create swarms
of your choice notes are allowed to
connect to swarms and quit or leave the
swamps on the flag so in and all the
installation is pretty easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swamp while covent is the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docker swarm
runs only docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and lot
of other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but lot of other things however
for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's the
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each part
can run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to docker's form uh gui so there's not a
good enough ui tool in docker's form at
least the ce edition of it which will
allow you to get to know what is running
on your containers what is the size of
the containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
portainer which gives you a good
visibility into your running docker
containers however there's nothing at a
swarm level that is provided by docker
kubernetes gives you an out of the box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also club it with some
metrics services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the nodes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way um this is little bit of a good ui
for kubernetes while for docker's form
there isn't anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture what comprises
of the kubernetes cluster what resides
in a master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to home and stuff like that all the
masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cuba ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cuba ctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running um cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster store before they go
ahead and decide any other work item or
anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asks
for some three replicas of a particular
port or a service to be running and if
at all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right api server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest
api endpoint and api server is the enter
point in case you don't want uh you know
somebody to access your cluster in case
you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as i mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a board as
a service as a container so in
kubernetes world there's something
called as a pod a pod is nothing but a
combination of a container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so sleeve nodes or the worker nodes
typically run these parts so that is
where the whole workload typically gets
run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the pod who has to
have access to the pod what is the state
of the pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
node should be the container runtime as
i mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have docker
running on it rkt running or lkc running
on it or any other container environment
that is running on it you have to ensure
that the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um affinity
towards any node on which these parts
are running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere so how would somebody
reach out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
altogether tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy contains a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubuntu's cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster and spin up this
cluster on aws platform finally we get
to the demo section of my tutorial now
that you guys are aware as to what is
kubernetes what is the use of kubernetes
you also know at a very very high level
what are the components of a cluster
what is a master node or a control plane
what are the components of a master node
and what should be existing in a worker
node you're probably thinking that it's
maybe pretty hard to kind of set this up
so let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple pre-node kubernetes cluster using
a tool called cops and i will be doing
this whole setup on my aws cloud okay so
what is cops cops is nothing but a
simple tool this is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
cops and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i'll do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cuba ctl which uh
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cuba
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node and submit jobs on my behalf
so let me begin by first logging into my
aws account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and
let me stick to one particular region
and let me bring up some one ec2
instance all right so let me launch my
instance let me choose um
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance i will name this as my cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
ports to be opened up so what i will do
is i will create a new security group
called open to the word i would not
recommend that you do this since i don't
want to it will take a long time for me
to specifically
to pick and choose um the ports that has
to be open for running my cluster i
don't want to do that i will open up all
the http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp i would
say from anywhere just to be on the
safer side also open http and https and
i will make this anywhere and anywhere
this is good for me i will say review
and launch all right so i chose a t2
micro instance just for the sake of
easiness have opened up all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen all right
now important part is like i would need
a key pair i need to create a new keypad
i will call this as simply learn
keys i will download this
key pair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
ssh keys with which i need to log into
my ec2 instance so i'll need to convert
this because i'm trying to connect from
my windows box i would need to convert
this into a ppk file so i have puttygen
i'm going to load my set of keys here
and convert that key into a ppk key all
right open all right i would say save
hang on save private key yes i would say
simply learn or simply learn private
private key and save this here and that
that's all so this is my public key
which is the pem file and this is my ppk
or my private key now using the private
key i will log into my ec2 instance okay
now my ec2 instance is up and running it
is running in this ohio region and this
is the ip address of my public ipads of
my machine so let me connect to it so i
use a moba x term which is nothing but
an ssh emulator you can use putty or any
of these sessions which allow you to do
an ssh this is my ip address of my
machine and since i've spun up an amazon
ami the user this is the default user i
would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im role and i will attach this
im role to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a role called as possibly
cops role i will create a role this role
will be used by my ec2 so i'm going to
click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cops fold
for ec2 all right so i'm going to create
a role which has got administrative
access rules i'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which i'm going to run my
cluster would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances talk to s3 buckets and all
that stuff all right now let us have our
running instance get powered by this
role so i will connect this role to my
running instance all right so this is my
um easy to instant that is running i'll
say action attach attach attach attach
replace im rules so there is no rule as
of now i would want my corpse roll for
easy this row that i created so i want
this new room to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or packet
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and
install cops cups is a pretty simple
installation it is available in a
particular location i have to just copy
this and ensure that i do a curl and i
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching uh the corpse tool
it's installing for me once it is copied
down let me change the mode so that i
can execute it and then also let me move
it to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the corpse installation let
me also do one other thing let me
install something called as cuba ctl so
this is what would be you know a tool
using which i'm going to be firing my
commands to my kubernetes cluster once
it comes up right this is a pretty
smaller executable so keep the ctl all
right so i have cuba ctl as well as cops
installed on my ec2 server now okay now
what i'll do next is i'm going to create
an s3 bucket in aws so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply
learn.kubernetes is the bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a dns entry or a dns
zone or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simply learn dot in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hosted zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted song great now let
me come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
uh s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bashrc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public oh sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these add export
them out as my ah variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my key pair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
cops command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't
configuration for specifying the master
or the control pane as well if i don't
specify that the default one is one so
i'm going to create
one primary or the master node and two
uh worker nodes size of my master node
size of the worker nodes uh what are the
zones where i want this to be created
and where do i store the cluster
information and okay i've already added
this master account this is actually not
required but this is the command that
i'm going to fire off so that i bring up
my cluster all right that went off uh
very fast but um this actually did not
create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster and uh and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with uh
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good 5 to 10 minutes for it
to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and uh two nodes or
the worker nodes all right so this is
the command for me to validate the
cluster and i'm gonna try it out first
i'm pretty sure that it will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good 5 to 10
minutes so what i'll do is i'll pause
the video now and i'll come back once
the server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good
eight to nine minutes uh since i started
my cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is simply
learn.n so what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some parts so let me
get back to my insta installation steps
here the validation cluster is done so
let me login to my since my cluster name
is simply non dot and this is the way to
log into my box so let me get into my
box so if you see here this is the host
name of the machine that i'm currently
in if you see this this is nothing but
our this cop server this is a server now
from here i'm trying to get into the
master box all right so if you see the
ip address has changed i was in a
different box i'm in a different box now
if i see host name you'll find a
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master node yep it's
153 this is the particular host so i'm
getting into this machine now so i
started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so i'm actually getting into my master
node and see if i can run some parts on
it all right so let me try kubectl uh
get cluster info try cube ctl get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
master node and um one master node and
two worker nodes so let me see if i have
some pods here cubic ctl get pods so
there's no pod as of now so what i'll
try to do is let me just pin up a very
very simple part just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct i have a simple uh node.js
application that i've built uh and i've
got a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker i've registered is
called simply learn docker hub and the
image name that i have here is called my
node app and i will use this image to
power one of my parts that i will run so
this is the way in which i'm going to
launch my pod let me show you this
commands cube ctl run the name for my
deployment that i'm going to run hyphen
iphone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn docker hub forward
slash my node app hyphen f1 replica is
equal to i want two replicas to be
running and the port that i want to
expose this particular part is on eight
zero eight zero so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as a deployment all right now let
me just say um i'm not really interested
in the deployment i'm interested in
checking if at all the parts are up and
running so i will say cube ctl get both
all right so that was pretty fast so i
have two parts that are running here
these are two replicas because i asked
for two replicas these parts are running
so i can run cube ctl describe pod
pickup all right i can pick up any of
the pod name and see what is the part
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image name id this is
actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot beat anytime if i
need to expose my pod outside i will
have to create a service for my part so
what i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
serial get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so i
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i am not specifying
what type and all i don't want to get
into the complications of uh what are
the different types of exposing the
service and all that stuff so if i don't
specify anything uh it gives me
something closer cluster id so this is
where my pod is actually exposed so let
me just check if at all this part is up
and running i'll just try a simple curl
command curl http colon this is my
cluster ip and the port is 8080 if at
all i hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me whatever i put
a simple
sys dot out kind of a thing where i'm
just printing um the container id of
whatever pod is serving uh makes a lot
of so i'm actually hitting my container
and i'm getting this output from the
content so everything looks good my
content is up and running uh so let me
just go and clean it up i'll say equip
ctl
delete deployment
simply learn app this should get rid of
all the parts that i created cube ctl
getpod all right these parts are
intermediating things let me just check
cubectl get services there's one service
i don't want this service let me delete
that cube ctl delete service i want this
all right that sounds good so let me
come back to my host my cop server from
where i'm running so i managed to
successfully verify this part see if
everything is up and running so what
i'll do is i'll just go ahead and
complete this demo by going and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it has now
got a mandate to go ahead and shut down
and clean up the whole instances and all
those things that are created as a part
of my deployment
hello this is matthew from simply learn
we're going to focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover what
and why you would use puppets what are
the different elements and components of
puppet and how does it actually work and
then we'll look into the companies that
are adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out and to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working states or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual document so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact that the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet master is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it
so manifest is the first subcomponent of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master associated with this
client certificate is the host name of
system a now master goes through the
certificate it sees the host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
i am willing to exchange information
with this system and i do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master sciences certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request
after this request the factor service
which is present on your clients
collects all the information regarding
the present state of your client so this
information could include the operating
system that's installed on them the
various number of software present on
them the versions of these software now
all this information is collected it's
called the fact and it's sent over to
the master at the master this
information that is the facts is
compared against the manifest so why
does the master do this the master
basically compares the facts against
manifest to know if what the manifest is
about to perform is already performed on
these systems so if the manifest has
some additional functionality they are
compiled into catalogs and then these
catalogs are sent over to the client now
remember those agent services which
existed in your clients here's where
they come in the agents take the catalog
and execute them on the client
once executed these catalogs make the
required changes on the client and a
report is generated this report is then
sent back to the master so the master
keeps record of all the changes that's
made in the system and this comes very
handy when one of the systems fail and
it's required to be rolled back to its
previous working state so this entire
procedure can be repeated n number of
times and can be repeated at regular
intervals so if you have a scenario
where a system needs to be configured
every 30 minutes what you can do is you
can set your interval and automatically
every 30 minutes your systems will be
configured so today i'll be showing you
how you can use puppet to install apache
on one of your client machines so we'll
be using two machines here we'll have a
server and we'll have a node machine the
server is essentially your master the
node is your client i'm just using the
term server and node instead because i
want to keep it very close to as they
are used in the commands now both these
machines are going to be sent to a 7
machines and i have oracle vm virtualbox
installed on my machine so on that i've
simply created two virtual boxes both
centos 7 of course so before we move on
to the actual demo i'll just take you
through the various steps so first we'll
install the puppet server on our server
or master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize the certificate and then it
will sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifests
so the manifesto is just the codes for
configuration and once that tool is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your cat logs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course it's the client
so let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server
so just so you can differentiate guys
the terminals have been set accordingly
puppet server has a black background
with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
a master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the name
the last word you see there that's the
new host name you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set so just type hostname
and yeah it's puppet so next we will
check the ip of this machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client
to communicate so for this we need to
remove certain firewalls so the command
for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's a command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just change this to xms
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start our puppet
server service
we enable the service
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that a puppet agent service is
installed we'll start the service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an ssl certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so a certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate the name of the certificate
itself is usually the host name of the
machine so our certificate's name should
be localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see here the certificate
is signed
sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is a sample file
we won't be writing anything in this
file as of now so we are just checking
here we are just creating this file and
then we'll go to our client machine and
just check the if we can access this
file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on our client machine
now a catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the http
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is a client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just cleared the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache
so as you can see we have successfully
used puppet to install the apache
service on our puppet client
and this is the end of our demo so let's
have a look at companies that are using
puppet today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppy today
include spotify google att so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool the answer can be seen if we look
at a specific company staples so staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in pocket so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you configure a specific
node in your server environment the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
if we step through the five key steps
for writing a manifest they are one
create your manifest and that is written
by the system administrator two compile
your manifest and it's compiled into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent and then five and clients are
configured to a specific and desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written it's written with a
very common syntax if you've done any
work with ruby or really configuration
of systems in the past this may look
very familiar to you so we break out the
work that we have here you start off
with a package file or service as your
resource type and then you give it a
name and then you look at the features
that need to be said such as ip address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types if we continue to write
our manifest and puppet the default
keyword applies a manifest to all
clients so an example would be to create
a file path that creates a folder called
sample in a main folder called etc the
specified content is written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say we want to be
able to trigger an apache service and
then ensure that that apache service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you'll have exactly the same results
on those machines now let's have a look
at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are four thousand eight hundred
and ninety three modules on the official
puppet forge these include modules from
the puppet labs and also from open
source contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge so before you write any
code for puppet you can check to see if
it's already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
sixty five hundred and eighty eight
participants apart from this on slack
overflow you have a big tag of puppet
labs in puppet which gives you a list of
only puppet questions
that's a good playground for you to
interact with people who are already
using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs it has almost five thousand modules
of puppet code so these are both puppet
labs and community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those five thousand
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs one of the other
benefits is they have built-in tests so
they follow all of the best practices
now if you write your own module you
also have to write your own tests and
you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and share with the community the puppet
dsl puppet dsl is a puppet domain
specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it it's kind
of a sub child of ruby because it
approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things so
it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify services to
be managed you can do things based on
the operating system you have so we'll
be writing a small puppet module which
will be using this puppet dsl we will do
that after we install the puppet server
and the client and then we will write a
simple puppet module to show how to use
the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be setting up
the machines using sudo dns because we
want to have a resolvable dns because
only by having a resolvable dns can we
use puppet because puppet uses the ssl
certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates of the client on the
server side and then we'll proceed with
writing an ntp module which we'll be
using for installation of ntp on the
client
and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl now we're
going to look at a demo here so we will
be setting up the machines we'll set up
a pseudo-dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client will be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
[Music]
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client i have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of ram
and four v cpus which i can show you
here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the i p addresses right click
normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then i will
change the host name so i'll say vim etc
host name
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a dd which will delete
that existing host name
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both these machines are ready i'm
going to find out the ips and use the
mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns which
means a fully resolvable dns name
so if i do hostname here you see my
hostname is puppetmaster in order to set
up a fake dns i need to go to the etc
hosts file
go to the end
then i say ipaddress hostname local
then space hostname
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a hostname hyphen f
you see it has a fully qualified domain
name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is xenial
so i'll say curl hyphen 0
https
apps dot puppet labs
dot com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command so i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my app package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get install
puppet hyphen
puppet server hyphen-y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server
so i'll say etc default puppet server so
by default
it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to 3 as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that i'll now start the puppet server so
i'll say systemctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
i'll also enable it at boot time so i'll
say systemctl enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time
now i also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say 192.1
and then puppet
hyphen server.local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the ip
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a host name
now we also need to set up the fake dns
here so i'll copy this host name
open the host line
go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name
so when i do a host name
it says puppet hive and client when i do
a host name hyphen f it says puppet
client local to install the puppet agent
on this machine i will need to download
the zenio packages so i'll say wget
https
apt.puppetlabs.com
slash puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc one
hyphensenial.deb
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here and then i'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apt
caches on this machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time so i'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
hyphen agent dot local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local
it is able to ping it and if i ping the
master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so i'll go
to my
to this directory which is opt puppet
labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and i'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the puppet master
then i'll say
hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when i go to the server
on the client side if i run the puppet
agent again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so search for apache module
here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install this is the
command for that but i will make sure i
run this command from the puppet home so
i'll go to the master i'll go to etc
puppet labs
code environments production
in this i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install
puppet labs hyphen apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version
and i'll hit enter
when i press enter it starts downloading
from the forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat stdlib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here etc puppet labs code
environments production manifest so in
this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify
and this is the main controller of how
the infrastructure looks in the site pp
i specify
that i want
puppethyphenclient.localnode to have the
apache module included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now is
since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module and compile
it and it may then make sure the server
is in a state so when i press enter we
see a lot of output it tries to
configure apache on this machine
and done now when i go to the front end
of this machine on this port i should be
able to see apache's default page so
this is apaches default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it's running
here
that is all we have from the uh puppet
module
and this concludes the demo today we're
going to go through a real tough battle
we're going to decide which is better
for your operations environment is it
chef puppet and support or salt stank
all four are gonna go head to head so
let's go through the scenario of why
you'd want to use these tools so let's
meet tim he's our system administrator
and tim is a happy camper putting and
working on all of the systems in his
network but what happens if a system
fails if there's a fire a server goes
down well tim knows exactly what to do
he can fix that fire really easily the
problems become really difficult for tim
however if multiple servers start
failing particularly when you have large
and expanding networks so this is why
tim really needs to have a configuration
management tool and we need to now
decide what would be the best tool for
him because configuration management
tools can help make tim look like a
superstar all he has to do is configure
the right codes that allows him to push
out the instructions on how to set up
each of the servers quickly effectively
and at scale all right let's go through
the tools and see which ones we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
are chef puppet and support and sort sex
and we have videos on most of these
software and services that you can go
and view to get an overview or a deep
dive in how those products work so let's
go and get to know our contestants so
our first contestant is chef and chef is
a tool that allows you to configure very
large environments it allows you to
scale very effectively across the entire
ecosystem and infrastructure chef is by
default an open source code
and one of the things that you find is a
consistent metaphor for the tools that
we recommend on simplylearn is to use
open source code the code itself is
actually written in language of ruby and
erlang and it's really designed for
heterogeneous infrastructures that are
looking for a mature solution the way
that chef works is that you write
recipes that are compiled into cookbooks
and those cookbooks are the definition
of how you would set up a node and a
node is a selection of servers that you
have configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my sql
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and
cons the pros for chef is that there is
a significant following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
git really well and provides for really
good strong version control some of the
consoles are really around the learning
speed it takes to go from beginner user
with chef to being an expert there is a
considerable amount of learning that has
to take place and it's compounded by
having to learn ruby as the programming
language and the main server itself
doesn't really have a whole lot of
control it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network all right let's look at our
second contender puppet and puppet is
actually in many ways very similar to
chef there are some differences but
again puppet is designed to be able to
support very large heterogeneous
organization it is also built with ruby
and uses dsl for writing manifests so
there are some strong similarities here
to chef as with a chef there is a master
slave infrastructure with puppet and you
have a master server that has the
manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then pushed out to the clients of an ssl
connection some of the pros with puppet
is that as with chef there is a really
strong community around puppies and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed reporting mechanism that makes
it easier for you as an administrator to
be able to understand your
infrastructure one of the cons is that
you have to really be good at learning
ruby again as with chev you know the
more advanced tasks really need to have
those ruby skills and as with chef the
server also doesn't have much control so
let's look at our third contender here
ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is the way the ansible
works is that it actually just pushes
out the instructions to the server
environment there isn't a client server
or master slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowell stands for yaml a markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know xml and xml is pretty easy if
you know xml you're going to get yamo
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focus is
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook in the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yamo
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now i do have to add a
proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and gamble itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here sort stack so source
stack is a cli based tool it means that
you will have to get your command line
tools out or your terminal window out so
you can actually manage the entire
environment via a salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yammer or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that sort snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with salt stack
so subscribe is very easy to use once
it's up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that
source tag is fairly late in the game
when it comes to actually having a
graphical user interface for being able
to create and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a ui environment for quite
some time all right so we've gone
through all four tools let's see how
they all stack up next to each other so
let the race begin let's start with the
first stage architecture so the
architecture for most of our
environments is a server client
environment so for chef puppet and salt
snack so very similar architecture there
the one exception is ansible which is a
client only solution so you're pushing
out the instructions from a server and
pushing them out into your network and
there isn't a client environment that
there isn't a two-way communication back
to that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is ansible it is going to be
the easiest tool for you to set up and
if you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
chef puppet and sourcetag aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's actually some great instructions
on how to do that setup in the online
community let's talk about the languages
that you can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural in that they actually
specify at how you actually supposed to
do the task in your instructions with
puppet and sword stack it's decorative
where you specify only what to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with ansible and sort
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're gonna love using them
they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and soul stack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chef are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layout and ansible and
sourcetech use secure socket hashing and
ssh as their communication tool bottom
line all four tools are very secure in
their communication so who wins well
here's the reality all four tools are
very good and it's really dependent on
your capabilities and the type of
environment that you're looking to
manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open source so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yaml-based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and we'll be really interested on what
your decision is please post in the
comments below which tool you have
decided to go with and what are the
challenges that you're coming up with
because we'll help answer those
challenges for you a very warm welcome
to all our viewers i'm anjali from
simply learn and today i'll be showing
you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
creates our ansible tool is installed
now we need to open an ansible host file
and there we'll specify the details of
our node or client machine
so this is a ansible hosts file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11.
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password
in my case it's the root's password and
that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write our
playbook the playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name and i'm going to name my
playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our node system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything is fine here we can
move on to our note system
and we'll just go to our browser
so if our playbook has been executed
here what should happen is that the
httpd service must be in the running
state and the web page that we created
should be hosted so let's just type
localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our webpage is displayed here so we come
to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible
ansible today as one of the key tools
that you would have within your devops
environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you and your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
they want to dig into the architecture
for ansible we're going to look at how
you would create a playbook how you
would manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible as a little
extra we're going to also throw in
ansible tower one of the secret source
solutions that you can use for improving
the speed and performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
case by looking at hootsuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operation side
of the dev ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of sam and like
yourselves sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
apache they could be database servers
running mysql and if you only have a few
servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain i mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it would we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where ansport
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible is a tool that really allows you
to create and control three key areas
that you'd have within your operations
environment first of all there's it
automation so you can actually write
instructions that automate the it setup
that you would typically do manually in
the past the second is the configuration
and having consistent configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of apache
servers and being able to guarantee with
precision that each of those apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
different
environments for server farms one is to
have a key server that has all the
instructions on and then on each of the
servers that connect to that main master
server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your hardware network through ssh
clients so a secure client
let's dig into some of the different
elements within that architecture and
we're going to take a first look at
playbooks that you would write and
create for the ansible environments so
the core of ansible is the playbook this
is where you create the instructions
that you write to define the
architecture of your hardware so the
playbook is really just a set of
instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yammer and this is
a standard language used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml 8 markup language that's just a
little tidbit to hide behind your ear so
let's have a look on one of these
playbooks it looks like and here we have
a sample yaml script that we've written
so you start off your jammer script with
three dashes and that indicates the
start of a script and then the script
itself is actually consistent of two
distinct plays at the top we have play
one and below that we have play two
within each of those plays we define
which nodes are we targeting so here we
have a web server in the top play and in
the second play we have a database
server that we're targeting and then
within each of those server environments
we have the specific tasks that we're
looking to execute so let's step through
some of these tasks we have an install
apache task we have a start apache task
and we have an install my sql task and
when we do that we can actually execute
a specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
apache and then setting the state of the
apache environment or starting the
apache environment and setting up and
running the my sequel environment
so this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with yama is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server where do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage in the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure in creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database server node
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointing to specific machines within
that environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yammer
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so let's ask you a simple question
what are the major opportunities that
ansible has over chef and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below pop them in there and
we'll get back to you and really want to
hear how you feel that ansible is a
stronger product or maybe you think it's
a weaker product as it compares to other
similar products in the market here's
the bonus we're going to talk a little
bit about ansible tower so ansible tower
is an extra product that red hat created
that really kind of puts the cherry on
the top of the ice cream or is the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command line tool however asphalt tower
is a framework that was designed to
access ansible and through the ansible
tower framework we now have an easy to
use gui this really makes it easy for
non-developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their devops plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nerds alright so we
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at hootsuite now hootsuite
if you not already use their products
and they have a great product hootsuite
is a social media management system they
are able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
hootsuite the challenge they had at
hootsuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite today the devops team at
hootsuite write out playbooks that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of
seconds
the bottom line is ansible has been able
to provide hootsuite with it automation
consistent configuration and free up
time from the operations team so that
instead of managing servers they're able
to provide additional new value to the
company ansible is currently the most
trending and popular configuration
management tool and it's used mostly
under the devops approach so what will
you be learning today you'll learn why
you should use ansible what exactly is
ansible the ansible architecture how
ansible works the various benefits of
ansible and finally we'll have a demo on
the installation of apache or the http
package on our client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo i'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
yemen and your inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and chef
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits here she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks
playbooks are written in yaml yaml
stands for yaml ain't a markup language
and it is honestly the easiest language
to understand and learn since it's so
close to english we also have the
inventory the inventory is a file where
you have all your nodes that require
configuration mentioned and based on the
kind of configuration they require they
are also grouped together so later in
the demo we'll have a look at how the
playbook and the inventory is written
and that will probably make it clearer
so of course a local machine needs to
communicate with the client and how is
this done this is done through ssh ssh
is your secure shell which basically
provides a protected communication in an
unprotected environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the notes and thus it's called a
push configuration tool now the
playbooks and the inventory are written
at the local machine and the local
machine connects with the nodes through
the ssh client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the playbook is executed
the task mentioned in the playbook is
compared against the current status of
the note and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
notes are configured to the desired
states so as i mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client and node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick
is also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we'll then write
the inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminal is open
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our host file so host file
here is basically the inventory it's
where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.127
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we're doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under task
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that their
siblings so the priority would be the
same
so to ensure that all your tasks are
coming under the tasks label make sure
they are not directly under name
so yeah that's pretty much it so when
you write your yaml file the language is
pretty simple very readable indentations
absolutely necessary make sure all your
spaces are correctly placed we can now
save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbooks executed as you can see
here gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the note that the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
the next step we need to just check on
our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your webpage is hosted hey
there are you exploring test automation
are you wondering why everyone is
talking about selenium around you do you
want to know what selenium is all about
if yes this is the video for you what
should you expect from this video before
you start understanding any automation
tool it's good to look back into what
manual testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a facebook
application and in facebook application
let's let's open the facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an accessibility testing you would do
a performance testing for this page or
say a response time after you say click
on the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
these test cases ready what do you do
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions tester's presence is required
all the time one is to keep doing manual
steps step by step again all the time he
also has to create manual reports group
them format them so that we get good
looking reports also send this reports
manually to all stakeholders then
collection of logs from various machines
where you have run your tests
consolidating all of them creating
repositories and maintaining them and
again since it's all as a manual process
there is a high chance of creating
manual errors there scope of manual
testing is limited for example let's say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
you will pick and choose your test cases
to execute that way you are limiting the
scope of testing also working with large
amount of data manually is impractical
which could be the need of your
application what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measures as a part
of your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on application
under test and hence manually performing
these kind of tests is not feasible and
to top it all up say if you are working
in an agile model where code is being
churned out by developers testers are
building their test and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
available for testing and this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run this test multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely becomes very tedious
and boring and is this the effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
automate one for faster execution two to
be less error prone and three the main
reason is to help frequent execution of
our test so there are many tools
available in the market today for
automation one such tool is selenium
birth of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like say rft and qtp just to name a few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks and he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing he realized the inefficiency in
manually testing this web application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner later
he made this open source and this was
renamed as the selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence and
since then selenium has become one of
the most powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like internet explorer chrome firefox
safari edge opera and even the headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as i said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in javascript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium id which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like java python
c-sharp ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages
also selenium supports different
operating systems it has suppose for
windows macs linux even ubuntu as well
so you can run your selenium test on any
platform of your choice
and hence selenium is the most popular
and widely used automation tools for
automating your web applications
selenium set of tools so let's go a
little more deeper into selenium as i
said selenium is not a single tool it is
a suite of tools so let's look at some
of the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium id it's the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is
integrated development environment
earlier selenium ide was available only
as a firefox plugin and it offered a
simple record and playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real-time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record and
replay tool selenium rc this is nothing
but selenium remote control it is used
to write web application test in
different programming language what it
does it basically interacts with the
browser with the help of something
called as rc server and how it interacts
its uses a simple http postgate request
for communication this was also called
as selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute text test cases it is obviously
the successor of the selenium rc which
we talked about because of certain
drawbacks which rc had so what webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike rc where the rc required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
it's selenium version comprised of it
had an ide rc and grid and as i said
earlier there were some disadvantages of
using rc so rc was on its path of
deprecation and web driver was taking
its path so if you look at selenium 2
version it had an earlier version of
webdriver and also the rc so they
coexisted from 3 dot onwards rc was
completely removed and webdriver took
its place there is also a four dot
version around the corner and it has
more features and enhancements some some
of the features which are talked about
are w3c webdriver standardization
improved id and improved grid now let's
look at each of the components in the
selenium suite selenium ide is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and is a very
simple and easy to use tool it is
available as a firefox plugin and a
chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called selenius commands and
they can be exported to the supported
programming language and hence this code
can be reused however this is mainly
used for prototyping and not used for
creating automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitation which any other record and
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium id so earlier selenium ide was
only a firefox extension so we saw that
ide was available since the selenium
version one selenium id died with the
firefox version 55 that was id was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium id has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on chrome as well as an add-on
on firefox browser so they completely
revamped this ide code and now they have
made it available on the github under
the apache 2.0 license and for the demos
today we'll be looking at the new id now
with this new ide also comes a good
amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using
idec on chrome or firefox but through
command prompt using your site runner
you can execute this test cases on any
browser thus by achieving your cross
browser testing control flow statement
so initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this id looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the firefox browser so on
this browser i already have the id
installed so when you already have an id
installed you will see an icon here that
says selenium id and how do you install
this you simply need to go to your
firefox add-ons here where it says find
more extension so just type in
selenium id and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see the selenium id just click on that
and now since i've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium id icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this id so when i
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so i already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so i'll go ahead and open that
so i'll say open existing project and i
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
facebook using a dummy user mail your
sorry username and password that's all
it's very simple script with few lines
and this is what it's going to do so
what we will simply do is we'll just run
the script and see how it works for that
i'm just going to reduce the test
execution speed so that you should be
able to see every step of execution here
all right so what i'll do now here is
i'll just adjust this window and i'll
just simply say run current test all
right so i'll just get this side by side
so that you should be able to see what
exactly the script is doing okay so now
you are able to see both the windows
okay so now it's going to type in your
user email here there you go and now it
will enter the password and it has
clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy ids it is you
are not able to log in here and you are
going to see this error window fine that
is what is the expected output here now
on the id if you look here after i
execute the test case every statement or
every command which i have used here is
colored coded in green so that means
this particular step was executed
successfully and then here in the log
window it will give you a complete log
of this test case right from the first
step till the end and your end result is
it says fb login which is my test case
name completed successfully let's look
at few components of this id the first
one is the menu bar so let's go to our
id all right so the menu bar is right
here on the top so here is your project
name so either you can add a new project
here or rename your project so since we
already have this project which is named
as facebook and then on the right you
have options to create a new project
open an existing project or save the
current project and then comes on
toolbar so using the options in this
toolbar you can control the execution of
your test cases so first one here is the
recording button so this is what you use
when you start recording your script and
then on the left you have two options
here to run your test cases the first
one is run all tests so in case you have
multiple test cases written here you can
execute them one by one sequentially by
using this run all test else what you
can do is if you just want to run your
current test this is what you would use
then id has this debugger option which
you can use to do a step execution so
say for example now whenever i run the
script it's going to execute each and
every command here sequentially so
instead if i just select the first
command and say do step execution all
right so what it does is the moment it
finishes the first command which is
opening of facebook right i think which
is already done here yeah all right so
once this is done it is going to wait
immediately on the second command and it
says pause debugger so from here you can
do whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is just going to simply go ahead
and complete the com complete the test
case now there is another option here
which is you see the timer there it says
test execution speed so to execute your
test cases in the speed you want say
whenever you're developing an automation
script right and say you want to give a
demo so you need to control the speed
sometimes so that the viewer is able to
exactly see all the steps which is being
performed and this gives you an option
to control that complete execution right
so do you see the grading here so we
have somewhere from fast to completely
slow execution so the previous demo
which i showed was i control the speed
and then i executed it so that we could
see every command how it is being
executed all right so what's the next
this is called as an address bar so
whichever wherever whenever you enter an
url here that is where you want to
conduct your test and another thing what
it does is it keeps a history of all the
urls which have used for running your
test then here is where your script is
recorded so each and every instruction
is displayed here in the order in which
you have recorded the script and then if
you look here you have something called
as login reference so now log is an area
where it records each and every step of
your command as in when they get
executed right so if you see here it
says open https facebook.com and ok so
that means this command was executed
successfully and after the complete test
case is done it gives you whether the
test case passed or failed so in case
there is a failure you will immediately
see this test case is filled in red
color also there is something called as
reference here for example say if i
click on any of this command the
reference tab what it is going to show
me is a details of this command which i
have used in the script it gives you the
details of the command as well as what
the arguments have been used or how how
is that you need to be using this
particular command okay so now what
we'll do is let's go ahead and write a
simple script using this id so with this
you'll get an idea how do we actually
record scripts in id so for that i have
a use case here a very very simple use
case so what we will do is we will open
amazon dot in then we will search simply
search for say product iphone and once
we get that search page where all your
iphones are displayed we will just do an
assert on the title of the page simple
all right so let's do that so first
thing what i need is an url okay so
first let me go to my firefox browser
here and say amazon.com so why i'm doing
this just to simply get the right url
absolute url path here and so that i
don't make any mistakes while typing in
the url okay so i got this so let me
close all this windows i don't need any
of this let's minimize this all right so
here what i will do in the tests tab
i'll say add a new test and name this
test as
amazon search done i'll say add now i'll
enter this url which i just copied it
from my browser and then i'll just say
start recording so what it
did was since i've entered the url in
this address box it just opened the
amazon dot in url now let's do our test
case so in my test case what i said was
i want to search for iphone once i have
this i'm just going to click on my
search button so now this gives me a
list of all iphones and then i said i
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is i have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium id options here
so in this i will select assert title
and then i will close this browser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
is created for me so it says open slash
because i've already provided the url
here so either you can replace it with
your regular url or you can just leave
it as it is so what i will do since this
is going to be proper script and i might
be using this to run it from a command
prompt also so i'll just replace this
target with the actual url and then what
it is doing it is setting a window size
then there are whatever i did on that
particular url on that website it has
recorded all the steps for me so this is
where it says type into this particular
text box which is my search box and what
did it type iphone this was the value
which i entered now there was one more
feature which i told you in this new id
which had which i said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this id is equal to tab search
textbook this is nothing but that search
box where we entered the text iphone and
it has certain identification through
which this ide identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is id is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
css and the xpath so how does this help
in failover is say tomorrow if amazon
dot in website changes the id of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular id fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the id it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of these becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then i have also
given a closed browser so right now what
i will do is i'll just comment this out
why because if i just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now i'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now i'll just say run the
current testing so your amazon n is
launched okay it is typed in the iphone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the lock so it's going to be a
running lock so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
facebook is also in the same lock so we
will have to see the log from running
amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right was executed successfully
assert title was also done and your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title i'll just modify this
and let's say just add some text i just
add double s here now this by
intentionally i am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the id behaves and how do you get to
know the failures okay so i'll just run
the disk test case again so before that
let's close the previous
window all right done and now
here i'll also uncomment the close
because anyway it's a failure which i'm
going to see which i should be able to
see it in the logs so i'll close the
browser after the execution of test case
okay so let's simply go and run the test
case okay amazon.com is launched it
should search for iphone now yeah there
you go all right
now it should also close the browser yes
it has closed the browser and it has
failed now see here now this is the line
where our command filled why because the
expected title was not there and if you
look in the logs it says your assert
title on
failed actual result was something
different and it did not match with what
we had asked it for so this is how
simple it is to use your id to create
your automation scripts so we saw all
the components of id we saw the record
button then i showed you the toolbar i
showed you the editor box and also the
test execution lock so now let's come to
what are the limitations of this id with
ide you cannot export your scripts your
test scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
the works data driven testing like using
your excel files or reading data from
the csv files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database for reading your test data or
perform any kind of database testing
with selenium webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
id like say for example test ng or
repotential so that brings us to the
next component of the suite which is
selenium rc selenium remote control so
selenium rc was developed by paul
hammond he refactor the code which was
developed by jason and was credited with
json as a co-creator of selenium
selenium server is written in java it is
used to write web application test in
different programming languages as it
supports multiple programming languages
like your java c perl python and ruby it
interacts with the browser with the help
of an rc server so this rfsave server
uses a simple http get and post request
for communication and as i said earlier
also selenium rc was called as selenium
1.0 version but it got deprecated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what
webdriver and we'll see why this
happened and what was that issue which
we had with the rc server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when jason
huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as javascript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every html has a
javascript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a javascript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this rca had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say
test.javascript here which you are
trying to access elements from anywhere
from the google.com domain so what used
to happen is every element which is
accessible e are the elements which can
belong only to google.com domain like
say for example mail the search or the
drive so any elements from this can be
accessible through your test scripts
however nothing outside the domain of
say google.com in this case was
accessible say for example if your test
scripts wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
which is under test on the same machine
and imagine if you have to do this for
every machine which is under test this
is not going to be feasible or even
effective all the time and this issue is
called as a same origin policy now what
the same origin policy issue says is it
prohibits a javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with scripts
from a domain different from where it is
launched and this is purely for the
security measure so if you have written
the scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot access
any elements outside the domain like as
we said in the example yahoo.com this
was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called a
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your core
your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your php or
your java or python and before we start
testing we need to launch this rc server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the cellini's commands and
these salinis commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your rc server the browser interaction
which happens through rc server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple http and post
and get request and that is how your rc
server and your browser communicate and
how exactly this communication happens
this rc server it acts like a proxy so
say your test scripts ask to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your rc
server launches the browser it injects
the javascript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your rc and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium core executes this actual
commands as javascript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
rc to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
javascript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the rc server to the browser
collecting the results again from the rc
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so rc had definitely lot of
shortcomings and what are those so rc
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your selenius command
and your browser the architecture of rc
is complicated why because of its
intermediate rc server which is required
to communicate with the browser the
execution of commands takes very long it
is slower we know why because every
command in this takes a full trip from
the test script to your rc server to the
core engine to the browser and then back
to the same route which makes your
overall test execution very slow lastly
the apis supported by rc are very
redundant and confusing so rc does have
a good number of aps however it is less
object oriented
so they are redundant and confusing say
for example say if you want to write
into a text box how and when to use a
type key command or just a type command
is always confusing another example is
some of the mouse commands using a click
or a mouse dot both kind of you know
almost providing a similar functionality
so that is the kind of confusion which
developers used to create hence
selenium rc got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while rc was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006. it's a cross-platform
testing platform so web driver can run
on any platform like say linux windows
mac or even if you have a ubuntu machine
you can run your selenium scripts on
this machine it is a programming
interface to run test cases it is not an
ide and how does this work actually so
test cases are created and executed
using web elements or objects using the
object locator and the web driver method
so when i do a demo you will understand
what this web driver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like rc so it is pretty fast why because
webdriver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the rc hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs
and this driver is responsible to make
the browser understand the commands
which you will be passing from the
script like say for example click of a
button or you want to enter some text so
through your script you tell which
browser you want to work with say chrome
and then the chrome driver is
responsible for interpreting your
instructions and to execute it on the
web application launched on the chrome
browser so like rc webdriver also
supports multiple programming languages
in which you can write your test scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various frameworks like test ng
junit n unit and report and change so
when we talk about the limitations of
webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various frameworks and tool
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level
what is in webdriver so webdriver
consists of four major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries
right or what we also call it as
language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if i go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all these
tabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that i'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings
and for each of the supported language
of selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you are
working with java here what you need to
do is you need to download your java
language binding so let us go back to
the presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of aps for us to
interact with the browser
and when we do the demo i will be
showing you some of this aps right and
these are nothing but the rest apis
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a json wire protocol
what is json javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as i said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation
so does selenium so let's look at what
these limitations are and if there are
any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like apm
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications
mobile applications are little different
and they need its own set of automation
tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this apm tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool
and using apm and selenium you can still
achieve mobile application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it
the next limitation so when we talked
about the components of selenium i said
that with webdriver we can achieve only
sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of webdriver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about
also if you want to know more details as
how do we work with the grid how do you
want to install that grid so do check
out our video
on simply learn website on seleniumgrid
third limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test ng report ng and even extent
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it
also there are other challenges uh with
selenium like selenium is not very good
with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like auto it
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium rc and the web driver
so rc has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
rc server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is lower in rc and much faster in web
driver why because in web driver we have
eliminated the complete layer of
selenium server
right that the rc server and we
established a direct communication with
the browser through browser drivers
it requires an rca server to interact
with the browsers we just talked about
it and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser
so rc again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant abs which kept developers
guessing as which api to use for what
functionality however webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
rc did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in web driver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website
then type the selenium in search bar and
click on it and click on the selenium
3.0 training so we are basically
searching for selenium 3.0 training on
the simply learn website first let's do
the steps manually and then we will go
ahead and write the automation script so
let's go to my browser
on my browser what i'll do is i'll let
me first launch the simply learn website
okay and here what my use case step says
is i need to search for
selenium and click on the search button
so once i do that it is going to give me
a complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with
simpler and what i'm interested in is
the selenium 3.0 training here once i
find this on the web page i need to go
and click on that all right so this is
all the steps which we are going to
perform in this use case okay now so for
writing the test cases i'll be using an
id which is eclipse i've already
installed my eclipse and also i have
installed selenium in this instance of
my eclipse all right so if you can see
the reference library folder here you
will see all the jars which are required
for the selenium to work next another
prereq which is required for selenium
and that is your driver files now every
browser which you want to work with has
its own driver file to execute your
selenium scripts and since for this demo
i'll be working with the firefox browser
i will need a driver file for firefox
now driver file for firefox is the
geckodriver which i have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers
now where did i download this from let's
go ahead and see that so if i go back to
my browser and if you go to your
selenium hq dot website you have to go
to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this you
will see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you are working on you need to
download that particular file now since
i am working on mac this is the file
which i am using if you are a windows
user you need to download this zip file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
firefox or a chrome driver for your
chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project
and just place the driver files here so
these are the two prereqs for your
selenium one is importing your jar files
like this and then having your drivers
downloaded and keep them under a folder
where you can reference to okay so now
we'll go ahead and create a class
i already have a package created in this
project so i'll use this project and
create a new class
so i'll say create new java class and
let's call this as
search training i'll be using a public
static void main and i'll click on
finish
so let's remove this auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your quotas what you need to
do is you need to define or declare your
driver variable using your class
webdriver so what i would do is i'll say
web driver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this id is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from org dot open sq dot selenium this
is the package which we will need all
right so you have a driver created which
is of the class web driver and now after
this i'm going to create three methods
all right so first method i will have
for
launching the firefox browser okay and
then i will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training
and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method i'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which i am going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
i'll be creating and from the public
static void main i will just call these
methods one after the other okay so
let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the firefox browser so i'll say public
void
since my return type is null or there is
no return type for this let's call it as
launch browser
okay all right now in this for launching
any browser i need to mention two steps
now the first step is where i need to do
a system.set property okay let's do that
first and then i'll explain what this
does i'll just say system dot set
property so this accepts a key and a
value pair so what is my key here my key
here is webdriver dot
gecko dot driver and i need to provide a
value so value is nothing but the path
to the gecko driver and we know that
this gecko driver which i am going to
use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
i am going to provide here so here
simply i need to say
drivers
slash gecko driver gec ko all right done
and let me close this sentence all right
now since i'm a mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a windows user and if
you are running your selenium scripts on
the windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be geckodriver.exe
so just make sure that your path which
you mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is i
need to just say driver is equal to new
firefox driver okay so this command new
firefox driver creates an instance of
the firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the firefox driver classes present
okay we did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the firefox
browser firm so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now i need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called
driver.get
driver.get what it does is whatever url
you're going to give it here in this
double quotes as an argument it is going
to launch that particular website and
for us it's a simply learn website so
what i do as a best practices instead of
typing out the url i go to my browser
launch that url which i want to test and
i simply copy it
come back to your eclipse and just
simply paste it so this ensures that i
do not make any mistakes in the url okay
so done so our first method is ready
where we are launching the browser which
is our firefox browser and then
launching the simply learn website now
the next method what is my next method
in my next method i need to give the
search string to search selenium
training on this particular website now
for that we need to do few things what
are those few things let's go to the
website again all right so
let me relaunch this let's close this
okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when i did a manual
testing of this i entered the text here
so now since i have to write a script
for this first i need to identify what
this element is for that what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to say right
click here and i'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which i can use
for finding this element so i i see that
there is an id present so what i'm going
to do is i'm just going to simply use
this id and then i'll just copy this id
from here go back to eclipse let's write
a method first so i'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training
or just search all right now in this i
need to use a command called driver dot
find element
by id is what i'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the id which i copied from the website
is what i'm going to paste here okay and
then what i'm going to do on this
element is i need to send that text the
text which i'm going to search for which
is selenium so i'll just say send keys
and whatever text i want to send i need
to give it in double quotes so for that
selenium so this is done so now i've
entered the text here and after entering
the text i need to click on this button
so for that i need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name i do
not have anything here all right so what
i can do is i can either use the class
name or i can write an x path since this
is a demo which we have already used id
locating technique i would go ahead and
use the x path here so for me to
construct an x path uh i will copy this
class first okay and then i already have
a crow path installed on my firefox so
i'll use the crow path and first test my
xbox so i'll just say double slash let's
see what was that element it has a span
tag okay so i'll have to use pan and add
class
equal to and i'll just copy the class
name here and let's see if it can
identify that element yeah so it is able
to identify so i'll just use this x path
in my code so i'll go back to eclipse
and i'll say driver dot find element by
dot x path
and the x path which i just copied from
crow path is what i'm going to paste
here and what is the action i need to do
here i need to say click
done so i have reached a stage where i
have entered this selenium
okay and then i have clicked on the
search button once i do this i know that
expected result is i should be able to
find this particular link here selenium
3.0 training okay and i should be able
to click on that so for that again i
need to inspect this so let's inspect
this selenium 3.2 all right so now what
are the elements this has now this
particular element has attributes like
it has a tag h2 then it has got some
class name and some other attributes so
i would again would like to use a xpath
here now this time while using the x
path i'm going to make use of a text
functionality so that i can search for
this particular text so i'll simply copy
this i'll go to my crow path the tag is
h2 so i'll say simply h2
okay and here i'll say text equal to and
this is the text which i copied i missed
out that yes there so i'm just going to
add an s okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see a blue dotted line it is
able to show us which element it is
identified so i'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ide eclipse so now
here what i need to do is i'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot x path
and paste the x path which we just did
and then again i have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that
now let's add an additional thing here
say after coming to this page after
finding this we want to say print the
title of this page now what is the title
of this page if you just hover your
mouse on this it says online and
classroom training for professional
certification courses simply so what i
will do is after doing all these
operations i will just print out this
page title on our console so for that i
have to just do this driver dot ah so
let's do a sysop so i'll say sis out
system.out.println okay and here i would
say
let's add a text here the page title is
and then let's append it with
driver dot
get title so this is the command which
we'll be using to fetch the page title
done now what is the last method i need
to add just to close the browser all
right so let me add a method here i'll
say public void close browser
and this is one single command which i
need to call i'll say driver dot quit
okay and then i need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so i let me use my class name which is
this so i'm going to create an object
obj is equal to
new class name and then using this
object first is i need to call the
method launch browser and then i'll call
the method search
right and then i'll call the method
close process done so technically our
script is ready with all the
functionality which we wanted to cover
from our use case now there are few
other tweaks which i need to do this and
i'll tell you why i need to do this now
for example
after we click here right after we click
on the search if you observed on your
website it took a little while before it
listed out all the selenium trainings
for us and visually when you're actually
doing it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of favorites now since
this is a demo for demo purpose what i'm
going to do is i'm going to use a
command called
thread.sleep and i'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this mainly for the demo
purposes you can use a thread.sleep
command
now this thread.sleep command needs us
to handle some exceptions so i'm just
going to click on add throws declaration
and say interrupted exception now same
thing i have to do it in my main
function also okay so let's do that and
complete it
all right so this is done so by doing
this what am i doing i'm ensuring that
before i click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the web page
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing i'm doing all
right and also now since you're going to
be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly i'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what i'll do is i'll just give a
simple thread.sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds wait should be good enough okay
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this
okay now our complete script is ready so
what i'll do is i'll just save the
script and then we will simply run the
script so to run the script i just say
right click run as java application okay
it says ask me to select and save i have
saved the script now so let's observe
how it runs okay the simplylearn.com
the website is launched so the selenium
text has been entered in the search box
it has clicked on the search okay all
right so now it did everything whatever
we wanted it to do all right so since we
are closing the browser you are unable
to see whether the selenium three dot
training was selected or not however
what i have given here is to fetch the
title after all these operations were
complete and if you see here the
complete operations was done and we were
able to see the page title here okay so
now what we'll do since we are unable to
see whether it clicked on the selenium
three 3.0 training or not i'll just
comment out the close browser the
command okay so we will not call the
close browser so that the browser
remains open and we get to see whether
did it really find the training link or
not okay so let me close this window we
don't need this firefox window close all
tabs and then i'll just easily execute
this script so i'll say run as java
application so save the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we've got the search results it
should click on selenium theoretical
training and yes it is successfully able
to click on that all right so now it's
not going to close the browser because
we have commented on that line however
it did print us the title here all right
so this is a simple way of using the
selenium scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with web
driver you can only do sequential
execution but in real time environment
you always have the need to run test
cases in distributed environment and
that is where selenium grid comes into
picture so grid was conceptualized and
developed by patrick the main objective
is to minimize test execution type and
how by running your test parallelly so
design is in such a way that commands
are distributed on multiple machines
where you want to run test and all these
are executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a windows
machine one of them is a mac machine and
another one is say a linux machine so
your requirement is to run the test on
all supported browsers and operating
system like the one which is depicted in
this picture so what you have to do is
first thing is you configure a master
machine or what you also call it as a
hub by running something called a
selenium standalone server and this
talent standalone server can be
downloaded from the selenium hq website
using the server you create a hub
configuration that is this node and then
you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so i'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our selenium hq website so you
can see here right on the top it says
selenium standalone server and this is
the latest version available so you just
need to download once you download this
keep a version of this one on your
master machine that is your hub and this
should also be present on your node
machines and there is a certain command
which you can use to install the server
as a node and as a master depending on
your configuration so once that is done
you have your master and your master or
the hub and the nodes created your
master can control on which nodes you
want to execute test now say if this is
a mac machine this is a windows machine
through your master or your hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what is then also you could have
a multiple combination of tests like say
for example smoke test to be run on all
these nodes that's the kind of
configuration you can create or a
certain component test to be run on say
only windows 10 with an edge browser or
say regression test on mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it needs to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does this grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications
it is pretty static each server is
configured in advance with a subset of
required browser instances available so
if you want to vary this you will need
to reconfigure so any configuration
tomorrow on any machines you want to
change it cannot be done automatically
you need to completely reconfigure that
node and then add it back to the grid
thirdly although it is available to run
on virtual servers it is actually not
designed as a cloud native application
and because of as a result of this it
isn't optimized to take advantage of
things like say distributed storage or
dynamic scaling or even automatic
failover so these are some of the
limitations of the grid advantages of
selenium speed and accuracy of course
since there is no manual execution your
test can run faster and with grid it
helps in parallel execution and you can
run or execute large volumes of test
within a very short time frame let's
take an example say before just before
the release of your product say during
the last lap of your testing you find a
bug and of course it has to be fixed so
the developer fixes the bug and you want
to run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support so this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you a lot of time from manual
execution and helping and achieving a
very broad test coverage
and we also saw that pretty easy to use
tool right so you can check out all our
videos and you can it's just a matte
matter of time that you can master the
skill of writing your automation scripts
reusability of course like any
programming language it provides you a
mechanism to reuse your code and avoid
redundancy well again let's see an
overall what are the limitations of
selenium itself now since selenium is
open source that is one of the biggest
advantage now there is a little
disadvantage which comes with that and
what is it you do not have much
technical support because it's an open
source code however there are loads and
loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like apm for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like auto it and securi which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
webdriver has limited limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
ng report ng and extent report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation today we're going
to go through interview questions that
you are likely to be asked if you are
interviewing for a job that focuses on
devops so there are approximately seven
sections that we cover in devops we go
from general devops questions source
code management with tools such as git
continuous integration and here we'll
focus on jenkins continuous testing with
tools such as selenium and then you also
have the operation side of devops which
is your configuration management with
tools such as chef puppet and ansible
containerization with docker and then
continuous marching with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
over the last five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
agile delivery which is on uh sprints to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around dev ops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which i see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chat bot or any digital solution that
you have and has an expectation when
you're going through and actually doing
a dev ops paradigm the old model would
be that you would capture requirements
from the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there would be these barriers between
each of those as we move faster through
from waterfall to agile what we saw is
that with agile we're able to respond
much faster to customer demands so
instead of it being weeks or months
sometimes in some cases years between
releases of software what we saw it
would was a transition to weeks and
months for releases on software now we
see with devops is that the release
cycle has shrunk even further with the
goal of continuously delighting the
customer how further has that release
cycle shrunk to there are companies that
have gone from having releases of once a
week or once every two weeks or once a
month to now having multiple releases a
day indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic
from a customer that's coming to your
website and or to your mobile app
they're going to see responses happening
continuously so that the customer is
always aware that you as a company are
listening to their demands and
responding appropriately you're able to
provide a more stable environment and
you're able to scale that environment to
the demands of the number of customers
that are using your services so how you
approach a project that needs to
implement devops so this is really an
exciting area for you to be in so there
are effectively three stages when it
comes to actually working in a devops
the first stage is an assessment stage
and think of this as the back of the
napkin ideation stage this is where you
are sitting with a business leader and
they're giving you ideas of what they
would like to see from feedback that
they've had from their customers this is
blue sky opportunity this is thinking of
big ideas that second stage and this
often comes as a fast follow to stage
one is actually proving out that concept
so developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the poc to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the poc so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your dev ops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting in
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that being delivered
so that once you actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that back into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to back fill the demand or work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production and
ensures that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you'd
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that
you're automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your environment
to meet the demands of both the solution
and the customer this makes software
development and release processes much
more faster and more robust so if we
look here we can actually see where
continuous integration and continuous
deployment come hand in hand so when you
actually start out with the initial
pushes of your code that's where you're
doing your continuous integration and
your continuous delivery and then at
some point you want to get very
comfortable with deploying the code that
you're creating so it's being pushed out
to your production environment one of
the things that's great about working
with the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment what
this means is that when you actually
come to deploying solutions to
production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management in dev ops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas and the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability to manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
it and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help and maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that with being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7 for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self-audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is amazon's
web services aws and they have really
five distinct areas them that you can
zero in on board services so when the
question comes up what is the role of
aws in devops you want to really hold
out your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that aws and
other cloud providers but aws is
certainly the leader in this space are
great for being able to provide support
for the role of devops so one of the
things that we want to be able to do
effectively when we're releasing any
kind of solution is to be able to
measure that solution and so kpis are
very important so you will be asked for
three important dev of kpis and so three
that really come to mind that are very
effective the first one is mean time to
failure recovery and what this talks
about is what is the average time does
it take to recover from a failure and if
you have experience doing this then look
at the experience you have and use a
specific example where you were able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impacts to your network
look like when you're doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so and how
many times did you deploy to a server
and something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then the second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
uh the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environments and
infrastructures code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that xml or ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
that software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yammer to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
uh source code management with git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to get is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
version control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up older
technologies such as older versions of
team foundation server though the
current version does actually have get
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files for the application and if the
centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows
for scalability when it comes to
building out your team so if you have a
team that may be in europe you can
actually then scale that team with
people from asia from north america or
south america very easily and not have
to worry about whether or not they have
the right code or the wrong code and in
addition to that if the actual main
server where you're checking in your
code does crash it's not a big deal
because you actually have each person
has a copy of the code so as soon as the
server comes back up you have to check
back in and everybody's running back as
if there was nothing that happened at
all so one of the questions you'll be
asked is to give the answer to some of
the commands you use for working with
git so if you were to be asked the
question is what is the git command that
downloads any repository from github to
your computer on the screen we have four
options we have git push git fork get
clone and get commit the answer in this
instance would be git clone now if you
want to be able to push code from your
local system to a github repository
using git then first of all you want to
be able to do is connect the local
repository to a remote repository and in
the example you may want to talk about
using the command get remote at origin
and then the actual path to a github
repository you could if you wanted to
actually at this point also talk about
other repositories such as get lab that
you can also work with or a private git
repository that would be used just for
the development team once you've
actually then added the local repository
into your local computer then the second
action you want to use is a push which
is to actually push your local files out
to the
master environment so you use the
command git push origin master so one
question you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bare repository and
a standard way of initializing a git
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using git init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
init and then the folder that creates is
the folder that creates all the revision
history related to the work that you're
doing in contrast
using the bear way you have a different
commands for setting that up so it would
be git init dash dash bear and it does
not contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git init initialization
so which of the following cli commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have git rm git mv get rm-r or none the
above well in this instance it would be
gatemv a question that you'll be asked
around commit is going to be what is the
process to revert a commit that has
already been pushed and made public and
there are two ways you can address this
the first is to actually
address the bad file in the new commit
and you can use the command git commit
dash m and then put in a comment for why
that file is being removed the second is
to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit id and the commit id and
it could be something such as 560e
0938f but you'd have to find that from
the commit that you had made but that
would allow you to
revert any bad files that you had
submitted so there are two ways of being
able to get files from a get repository
and you're going to be asked to explain
the difference between git fetch and git
pull so get fetch allows you to fetch
and download only new data from a root
new repository it does not integrate any
of the new data into your working files
and it can be undone at any time if you
wanted to break out the remote tracking
branches in contrast git pull updates
the current head branch with the latest
changes from the remote server so you
get all of the files and downloaded it
downloads new data and integrates it
with the current working files you have
on your system and it tries to merge
remote changes with your local ones so
one of the questions you'll get asked
about git is what is a gate stash so as
a developer you will be working on the
current branch within a solution but
what happens if you come up with an idea
where it's something that will take a
different amount of time for you to be
able to complete but you don't want to
interrupt the mainline branch so what
you can actually do is you can actually
create a branch that allows you to start
working on your own work outside of the
main line branch and this is called git
stash allows you to be able to modify
your files without interrupting the
mainline branch so you once you start
talking about branching and get be
prepared to answer and explain the
concept of branching so essentially what
it allows you to do is
have a mainline master branch that has
all the code that the team is checking
in and checking out against but allows
you to have an indefinite number of
branches that allows for new features to
be built in parallel to the mainline
branch and then at some point be
reintroduced to the main line branch to
allow the team to add in new features
and so if we look through the merge and
get rebase these are the two features
that you'd be using continuously to be
able to talk about how you take a branch
and merge it back into the mainline
branch so on the left hand side we have
git merge which allows you to take the
code that you're creating and merge it
back into the master on the right hand
side what you have is a slightly
different approach this is for projects
where you reach a point in a project
where you go okay we're going to
effectively restart the project at this
point in time and we want to ignore the
complete history that's happened before
that and that's called git rebase and
that would allow you to rewrite the
project history by creating a brand new
mainline branch that ignores all other
previous branches that have happened
before it you can if you want to very
quickly and easily find out all the
files that have been used to make a
particular commit so when somebody asks
you the question how do you find a list
of files has been changed in a
particular commit you can actually say
that all you have to go is find the
command git diff dash tree dash r and
then the hash that you'd use for the
commit and that would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict in git and how
can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have uh two
or more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a highlight of conflict markers and
you'll be able to select which conflicts
you want to keep on which you want to
merge and which ones you want to change
so it's a step through how you would
actually resolve a merge conflict and
the first step would be under github you
want to be able to pull the repository
name and then the pull request around
that repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve they'll pull up a file that
will list out all of the conflicts for
you near the bottom of that file will be
a list of the requests that need to be
resolved and then if you need to make a
decision on which branches you want to
keep or which ones you want to change
that will have to be something you have
to put in instructions inside of the
file you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolved in github so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then onto the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all the
conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the cd change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then
you want to be able to generate a list
of the files that are affected with the
merge conflict and in this instance here
you can actually see the file style
guide.md has a merge conflict in it and
as before with working with github you
actually go through and use it a text
address and then you can use any text
editor but as you go through and edit
out what you want to keep and what you
want to
manage in your conflict so you actually
have a resolution that's been created so
that you'll be able to then once you
you're using the conflict markers you
can actually merge your files together
so that the solution itself will allow
you to
incorporate your commits effectively
into the resolution once you've gone
through and applied your changes you're
able to then merge the conflicted
commits into a single commit and able to
push that up to your remote repository
all right let's talk about the next
section which is continuous integration
with jenkins so the first question
you'll be asked about with jenkins is
explain a master slave architecture of
jenkins so the way that jenkins is set
up is that the jenkins master will pull
code from your remote git repository
such as github and will check that
repository every time there is a code
commit it will distribute the workload
of that code and the tests that need to
be applied to that code to all of the
jenkins slaves and then on request the
jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
jenkins file and simply put a jenkins
file is a text file that has a
definition of the jenkins pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit trail for
that pipeline and also provides a single
source of truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs jenkins from the
command line is it java jar jenkins.war
java dashwar jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar java dash war
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins dot war so when working with
jenkins you're going to be asked what
are the key concepts and aspects of
working with a jenkins pipeline and you
want to really hold out your fingers
here and go through four key areas and
that is pipeline node step and stay so
pipeline refers to the user-defined
model of a cd continuous delivery
pipeline node are the machines which is
which are part of that jenkins
environment within the pipeline step is
a single task that tells jenkins what to
do at that particular point in time and
then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to define dependency in maven and do we
have a build.xml
b
palm.xml c dependency.xml
or d
version.xml and the answer is
palm.xml working with jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovyscript as
their domain-specific language for
jenkins and there are one or more note
blocks that are used throughout the
entire pipeline on the left hand side
you can actually see what the actual
script would look like and the right
hand side shows what the actual
declaration for each section of that
script would be the second type of
jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or c you can
actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plugin within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot hpi plugin file into the jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
dot plugin.hpi.pen and once you've
completed these three steps restart
jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to true which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false security will
disable allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time jenkins
is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment slash safe restart so let's
go into the fourth and final section of
this first video which talks about
continuous testing with selenium so the
first question you will be asked most
likely around selenium are what are the
four different selenium components and
again you will want to hold open your
fingers because there are four distinct
environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selenium ide you have selenium remote
control or selenium rc you have selenium
web driver and then selenium grid you'll
be asked to explain each of those areas
in more detail but let's start off with
by looking at selenium driver what are
the different exceptions in selenium
webdriver so it's useful to remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow of that
program's instructions and so we have
four we have a timeout exception an
element not visible exception no such
element exception and a session not
found exception and each of those if we
step through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium web driver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancelium test and application in an
android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported tests within selenium so when
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by
cylinder you can answer that and there
are three different types of tests first
is a functional test second is a
regression test and third is a load
testing test the functional test is a
kind of black box testing in which test
case are based on a specific area of
feature within the software a regression
test helps you find any specific areas
that functional tests or non-functional
areas of the code wouldn't be able to
detect the load testing test allows you
to monitor the response of a solution as
you increase the volume of hits and how
you're using the code are put onto it an
additional question you'll be asked is
how can you get a text of a web element
using selenium well the get command is
used to achieve text of a specific web
element now it's important to remember
however that the command does not return
any parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction api and the advanced user
interaction api is something that can be
scripted into your tests and it allows
you for
capturing methods such as a click and
hold and drag and drop mass events and
then keyboard down or keyboard up key
release events so that if you want to to
capture say the use of control shift or
a specific function button off the
keyboard you'd be able to capture those
of the following four elements which of
these elements is not a web element
method a get text b
size
c get tag name d send keys and it's b
size you're going to be asked to explain
what is the difference for when we use
find element or find elements and so if
we look at find element find element
finds the first element in the current
web page that matches the specified
located value in contrast find element
finds all of the elements on the web
page that matches the specified value
when using webdriver what are the driver
close and driver quit commands and these
are two different methods used to close
a web browser session in selenium so
driver close will close the current web
browser which your focus is set and
driver quit closes all the browser
windows and ends the web driver session
completely the final question that you
are likely to be asked in using selenium
is how can you submit a form using
selenium well in this instance that's
relatively easy the following lines of
code will let you submit a form in
selenium which would be web element el
equals driver dot find element and then
you put in the id and the element id and
then l submit open close parentheses
semicolon so let's just get into the
first section which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl certificates used for chef
really fundamentally your immediate
answer should be security ssl provides
for a very high level of private
security and private and public key
pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using ssl and you're using the
private public key model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked um some questions
such as the following which is the
following commands would you use to stop
or disable the http service when the
system boot and you'll typically get
four responses and there'll be
system ctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http dot service system disable httpd or
the final option which is system ctl
disable
httpd.service your answer should be the
first one which is hashtag system ctl
disable http dot service so chef comes
with a series of tools that allow it to
function effectively and one of the
tools that you're going to be asked
about is what is test kitchen and test
kitchen is essentially a command line
tool that allows you to be able to test
out your cookbook before you actually
deploy it to a real node so some of the
commands that you would use are for
instance if you want to create an
instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge so a question
you'll get is around chef is how does
chef apply differ from chef client so
fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppets and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version three now something to bear in
mind when you're going through your
interview process is that the tools that
are used within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is uh being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins
so what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppet one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class in puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this can
include services files and packages and
we have on the screen here an example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within and support and
really the answer comes down to two
things one is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables in the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture and it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the docker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so
docker file actually is used for
creating docker images using the build
command so let's go through and show on
the screen what that would look like and
this would be an opportunity where if
you're actually in a technical interview
you could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you are
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub
and you can use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read only file
system the docker container is a
collection of the runtime instances of a
docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yaml or
writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with json
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame reference json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a javascript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have a docker
registry is an open source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images whereas in
contrast for repository it's a
collection of multiple versions of a
docker image in a registry a user can
distinguish between docker images with
their tag names and then finally on the
registry docker also has its own default
retreat called docker hub for the
repository it is a collection of
multiple versions of docker images it is
stored in a docker registry and it has
two types of public and private registry
so you can actually create your own
enterprise registry so you're going to
be asked you know what other cloud
platforms that support docker really you
know list them all and we have listed
here amazon web services microsoft azure
google cloud rackspace but you could add
in their ibm bluemix could put in red
hat really any of the cloud service
providers out there today do support
docker it's just become an industry
standard so what is the purpose of
expose and publish commands in docker so
if we go through expose is an
instruction used in docker file whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with publish is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish would do the example docker run
dash d dash p and then 0.0.0.80
a colon 80 as our command line so let's
look at continuous monitoring so with
continuous monitoring how does netgio's
help in continuous monitoring of systems
applications and servers and so this is
really just a high-level question of
using nagios within your environment and
you should be able to just come back
very quickly and say nagios allows you
to help manage the servers and check if
they're being sufficiently utilized and
if there are any task failures that need
to be addressed and so there are three
areas of utilization and risk that you
want to be able to manage this is being
able to verify the status and services
of the entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with web services and apis that
are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negatives help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negatives process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negative web interface to be able to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagios
remote plugin executor or the mpre of
nagios so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
cpu load etc what are the ports used by
nagios for monitoring purposes in this
example there are three and they're easy
to remember so i would memorize these
three but they're essentially ports five
six six six five six six seven and five
six six eight so there are two types of
checks within nine years so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nagios so an active check and
is initiated by the nagios process and
is run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to
nigeria's for processing and to continue
with this for what is an active and
passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios daemon negas will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plug-in will then
check the operational state of the host
oil service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and i guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negotiate may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in nagio so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how nagios
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that's read by both
nagios processor and the cgis so this
will allow you to be able to manage the
main configuration file that's placed
into your settings directory so what is
the nagios network analyzer and again
hold out your four fingers because there
are four options here so the nagios
network analyzer are one provides an
in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats 2
allows system admins to gather high
level information on the health of your
network 3. provides a central view of
your network traffic and bandwidth data
and then 4 allows you to proactive in
resolving outages abnormal behavior and
threats before they affect critical
business processes
so what are the benefits of http and ssl
certificate monitoring with nagios so
with http certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast detection
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the ssl
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how nagios itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including microsoft visual pc
vmware zen amazon ec2 etc etc so just
make sure you get that right off the bat
nuggets it was able to provide
capabilities tomorrow an assortment of
metrics on different platforms it allows
for ensure for quick detection of
service and application failures and has
the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including cpu usage
memory networking and vm status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use
specifies the name of the template
object that you want to inherit its
properties and variables from and
register indicates whether or not the
object definition
should be registered to nagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can actually write down and
show someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagios
said to be object oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format that you can use in
your object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical of
object oriented development and is now
applied for the nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
are services hosts commands and time
periods so finally explain what is state
talking in nagios and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about state stalking so state
stalking is used for logging purposes in
nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service that nagios
will watch over very carefully it will
look any changes it sees in the output
of the check results and then finally
helps the analysis of log files
and with that we have reached to the end
of day five so far we have learned the
important development tools of devops
on the day6 of devops learning week we
will reveal the next stage where you get
to master the most frequently asked
devops interview questions
so stay tuned and don't miss it thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
to stay tuned for more from simply long